visage médiatique avec d'ores et déjà et
sans être exhaustif des entités comme
canal+ et ses news dans l'audiovisuel
paris match le jdd il est magasinier ou
prisma dans la presse europe 1 dans la
radio editis et achètent dans l'édition
pagny g dans la production et havas
temps la publicité je pense que le
rapporteur reviendra sur les différentes
entités de votre groupe lempereur
l'ampleur prise sous votre direction par
vivendi dans les médias entre donc
pleinement dans le champ de notre
commission denquête elle renvoie à des
interrogations que nous nous posons sur
les conséquences de cette concentration
mais aussi sur l'efficacité des cards
flou législatif existant ou à créer pour
tenir compte des logiques économiques
tout en assurant le respect du
pluralisme je ne vous surprendrai pas en
vous disant que votre nom revient de
manière très régulière dans les
auditions que nous avons menées jusqu'à
présent sans doute ceci est lié à la
façon dont vous concevez votre rôle
d'actionnaires sensiblement différent de
celui des autres grands capitaines
d'industrie qui comme vous ont investi
dans les médias avec un
interventionnisme sans doute plus
assumer un management très directif
c'est aussi liée au positionnement prix
par ses new skies n'est pas le plus
important des médias détenus par vivendi
en termes de chiffre d'affaires ou de
part d'audience mais qui est
certainement celui dont on parle le plus
depuis que sa ligne éditoriale de la
fait entrer d'après de nombreux
observateurs dans le champ des médias
d'opinion la commission a donc souhaité
vous donner la possibilité de vous
exprimer directement pour nous donner
votre vision de grands actionnaires des
médias à la fois sur la dépendance mais
également sur l'avenir d'un secteur en
bonne partie fragilisé par l'arrivée des
géants du numérique je vous propose
l'organisation suivante qui est
d'ailleurs celle que nous avons mis en
place pour toutes nos auditions je vais
vous laisser la parole pour dix minutes
de propos introductif je serai strict
sur le respect du temps de parole non
pas pour brimer votre expression mais
tout simplement pour permettre qu'après
nous ayons un dialogue à travers des
questions et des réponses avec
des sénatrices et sénateurs de la
commission ce sera le rapporteur qui
commencera la première série de
questions je rappelle que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du sénat elle fera également
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié enfin
je rappelle pour la forme qu un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
denquête seraient passibles des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal je vous précise également
qu'il vous appartient le cas échéant
d'indiquer vos éventuels liens
d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts en
relation avec l'objet de la commission
denquête et enfin comme nous sommes une
commission denquête je vais vous inviter
monsieur bolloré a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je te
jure merci monsieur bolloré je vous
laisse la parole pour dix minutes
on m'a demandé donc de dire quelques
mots de présentation
peut-être rappeler rapidement mon
parcours je travaille depuis un peu plus
de 50 ans j'ai passé dix ans dans la
banque en terminant un dss de droit et
puis j'ai été appelé à passer
quarante ans dans une entreprise
industrielle fondée par ma famille près
de quimper en effet je suis né dans une
grande ancienne famille bretonne et
l'entreprise qu'elle dirige était tombé
en difficulté j'ai donc été appelé à
quitter la banque pour ma clé au
redressement et au développement de
cette entreprise
quand je suis arrivée elle faisait 20
millions de chiffre d'affaires elle en
fait aujourd'hui un milliard elle
employait un peu moins de 800 personnes
et nous sommes un peu plus de 80000
personnes aujourd'hui dans le groupe
seul son siège social n'a pas bougé il
est toujours à ergué gabéric qui n'est
pas un paradis fiscal des antilles
néerlandaises tout cas pas pour
l'instant mais un village à côté de
quimper
mon travail est la clé de cette
croissance qui a été obtenu malgré des
crises économiques des problèmes des
pandémies comme en ce moment a consisté
pour le résumer à choisir recruter faire
travailler ensemble des personnes leur
donner les moyens du développement et
surtout à l'international et puis
évidemment insuffler le courage et
permettre aux équipes de travailler sur
le long terme car on s'aperçoit que les
actionnaires fine ancien souvent ont des
problèmes de court terme et on
s'aperçoive que quand on a la
possibilité de travailler sur le long
terme les choses se terminent mieux
aujourd'hui fini de laisser ma place de
dirigeant ou plutôt de conseillers
puisque depuis deux trois ans je suis
passé de dirigeants à conseiller et la
chance d'avoir ma famille qui accepte et
poursuivre cette saga industrielle et
qui va représenter la septième
génération elle s'investit à fond avec
évidemment des équipes dirigeantes de
grande qualité qui s'entendent avec eux
en ce qui concerne la partie du groupe
qui vous intéresse c'est à dire les
médias c'est le même chemin que je vous
ai décrit que nous avons fait d'abord
c'est un chemin que nous avons entrepris
à 20 ans
les gens parlent depuis peu de temps
mais ça fait 20 ans qu'on a commencé
avec une stratégie claire qui était dire
au fond qu'il existe un vivier de
contenus très important à partir de
notre culture française européenne et
qu'à côté
du soft power américain de tous ces
contenus qui viennent
d'amérique et qui songe à les dire
toujours à peu près les mêmes à côté des
contenus asiatiques qui arrivent de plus
en plus et bien les contenus européen
apporte une certaine fraîcheur qui est
sans doute extrêmement intéressante non
seulement à conserver pour le respect de
notre passé mais surtout à exporter et
donc c'est à partir de cette idée qui
était que nous pouvons créer un champion
de la culture européenne un champion la
culture française que nous avons entamé
ce chemin il ya 20 ans
c'est un secteur contrairement à ce que
croient les gens qui peut garder gagner
beaucoup d'argent c'est le deuxième
secteur le plus rentable dans le monde
après le luxe j'ai toute une série de
slide que je pourrais vous montrer tout
à l'heure si si vous le souhaitez si
vous en avez besoin
mais donc notre stratégie la culture
française la culture européenne face à
la culture américaine et asiatique des
équipes que nous avons recruté au fur et
à mesure de ses 20 ans jean christophe
thiery que vous connaissez qui nous a
rejoints les premiers avec philippe
labro et puis toute une équipe toute une
série de gens qui nous ont rejoint
maxime saada que vous allez recevoir je
crois évidemment à nos puits fontaines
et plein d'autres et puis nous nous
sommes donné les moyens d'agir sur le
long terme
contrairement à ce qui est écrit un peu
partout
nous sommes encore tout petit nous
progressons c'est vrai mais nous sommes
encore tout petit et je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure si vous le souhaitez des
tableaux qui montre comme nous sommes
petits et en dehors du fait de savoir si
les autres sont plus grands tout cas ce
qu'on peut regarder c'est que le vix
20-10 d'aujourd'hui est infiniment plus
petit que le vix 20 10 10 à 20 ans et
qui à l'époque en tout cas ne posait
aucun problème
voilà donc je suis à votre disposition
j'espère avoir respecté les dix minutes
pour répondre à vos questions j'indique
simplement que je réponds à titre
individuel puisque je n'ai aucun titre
ni pouvoir à la tête du groupe i 20 10
du groupe bolloré du groupe canal et
encore moins du groupe lagardère mais
bien évidemment je m'exprime un titre
individuel semble dérobé à la moindre
des questions que vous souhaiteriez me
poser
merci nous allons sans plus tarder
commencer les questions avec celle du
rapporteur david assouline
bonjour monsieur bolloré bonne année
notre commission denquête veut mettre en
lumière la réalité du paysage
audiovisuel et de la presse dans notre
pays
les phénomènes de concentration qui se
développe
comprendre leurs motivations
et analyser l'impact que cela peut avoir
sur le secteur économique mais aussi et
surtout sur l'exercice de la démocratie
du pluralisme de la liberté de
l'indépendance des médias qui sont des
principes inscrits à la constitution
dans la constitution d'ailleurs depuis
que je permis de l'amendé dans ce sens
au cours de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
ces principes sont à l'article 34
votre témoignage est tout à fait
important pour nous nécessaire attendu
parce que vous êtes devenu un acteur
important dans cette concentration
vos activités d'origine vous en avez
parlé mais c'est bien pour savoir de
quoi on parle
de deux
d'énumérer
les activités de votre groupe d'origine
essentiel
dans les transports et la logistique
fret maritime terrestre ou aérien les
opérations douanières des concessions
portuaires dont une présence dans 42
port et 17 concession de terminaux à
conteneurs en afrique que la
distribution d'énergie logistique
pétrolière et d'esprit distribution de
produits pétroliers
le chemin de fer transports de passagers
mais aussi
maintenance et on peut dire aussi que
avec la fabrication de films plastiques
de solutions de stockage de battre et de
mobilité électronique
avec aussi une activité à travers ce aux
fins
de l'un des principaux planteurs dans le
monde avec près de 200 mille hectares de
palmiers à huile à vias en asie en
afrique principalement au cameroun au
nigeria au liberia
à partir de là vous l'avez signalé ce
n'est pas nouveau dans les années 2000
vous avez commencé plutôt timidement au
début à aller dans le secteur des médias
dans les années 2010 au milieu vous avez
accélérer ce mouvement est aujourd'hui
dans les derniers mois des opérations
encore de conan verdure au lieu et ce
qu'ils ont fait souvent l'actualité
pour que l'on comprenne de quoi on parle
g je vais énumérer
ça peut être fastidieux mais ça donne la
dimension de pourquoi vous êtes là
devant nous alors que nous parlons
justement de la concentration dans les
médias avec les groupes où vous avez
100% il y à ses huit ses stars ses news
studiocanal my canal canal vod canal+
règle la chaîne canal toutes ses
variantes canal+ cinéma canal+ sport
séries etc car plus vietnam capuche ex
canalsat canal international calédonie
canal+ caraïbes canal+ réunion canal+
afrique vous avez aussi les multi
thématiques s'il n'est plus planète
téléthon pee wee foot+ comédie infosport
saison olympia tv canal+ polska
canal+ meehan marc aymes 7 avec télésat
etc et vous avez aussi dans les jeux
vidéo de
et dans le monde des métiers du
spectacle vivant de la billetterie des
festivals et de la production city quête
info conserve c'est parce copyright
group une live théâtre de l'oeuvre
vivendi sport can à l'olympia l'olympia
vie lundi bang marketing dans le monde
encore où vous êtes à 100% de la
publicité on va dire havas créative
arena médias renold l'institut csa
l'institut de sondage mettez cbtc fusil
l'x et je vais passer toutes les
filiales davasse qui sont très
importantes en france et partout dans le
monde encore à 100% la plateforme
d'hébergement de vidéos dailymotion
et puis le groupe prisma médias dans le
domaine des magazines et d'édition ça
m'intéresse capital cuisine actuelle
femme actuelle femme actuelle seniors
flow gala géo harvard business review
management national geographic néons
prix pris ma télé loisirs télé 2
semaines tv jantes voici vous france
catholique que dans le domaine de
l'édition de la presse l'hebdomadaire
et vous avez baissé
en capital mais vous êtes participants
encore dans universal music group qui
est le premier label de musique au monde
et puis
vous avez aussi des maisons d'édition et
dit whitt avec first et first
interactive dans la collection pour les
nuls ou gronde les livres du dragon d'or
tana cuisine loisirs créatifs voyage
écologie 404 édition les escales et les
escales domaine français l'one lonely
planet france est ma langue au chat
éditions solar poulpe fiction slalom
livre jeunesse
vous avez la maison place des éditeurs
avec plomb et presses de la renaissance
éditions perrin éditions belfond
éditions omnibus hors collection presses
de la cité vous avez le groupe robert
laffont avec les éditions robert laffont
les éditions julliard nil éditions
éditions seghers vous avez dans
l'univers des poches les 10-18 fleuve
édition courue kawa pocket et pocket
jeunesse 12 21 l'éditeur numérique
d'autres maisons d'édition celle du
cherche midi la découverte sonatine
éditions
xo éditions éditions héloïse d'ormesson
éditions télémaque et
aujourd'hui vous êtes à
49,45 dire nul 13 %
dans le groupe lagardère
avec nos pea qui est
imminente dans le mois qui va nous
suivre et là vous êtes à europe 1 rfm
virgin radio paris match journal du
dimanche le groupe hachette c'est armand
colin les éditions albert rené
calmann-lévy desseigne et aura les
taulards à des scènes et tolra de coqs
d'or du no edicef édifiant ce et 10 et
des éditions des deux terres éditions du
chêne éditions stock éditions fayard
éditions mille et une nuits l'édition
mazarine pauvert grasset grasset
jeunesse édition fasquelle bibliothèque
charpentier gauthier l'achète à hachette
édition
10 passion par dont hachette français
langue étrangère à cette jeunesse
hachette pratique achète roman hachette
tourisme avec le guide du routard
éditions hazan harlequins arabe groupe
alexandre hatier edsel interdition istra
lattès larousse le livre de paris audio
l'ip le livre de poche marabout
microsoft press octopus france orbite
pika édition je vais pas énumérer vos
participations dans des médias étrangers
mais bon il y a prisa vous êtes un oeuf
une % dans quatre journaux et de radio
el país et cetera et puis aussi des
médias 28,10 % dans le secteur de la
communication trois chaînes de
télévision italiennes canal 5 italiens
est un quatre et c'est donc c'est de
cela que l'on parle et j'ai envie de
vous poser une question simple à la
suite de cette énumération
pourquoi
constitué cet empire quel est votre
intérêt votre passion pour construire un
tel empire médiatique dans notre pays
je vais vous demander d'appuyer sur le
bar d'un taux historiquement nous étions
dans le papier je rajoute ocb auquel
nous tenons beaucoup comme marc ristori
si vous m'autorisez
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président je vais vous montrer je ne
sais pas si vous voyez bien sinon j'ai
quelques
documents
vous voyez bien sinon j'ai des documents
voilà ça c'est pour replacer vivent un
10 qui est le champion français voyez
c'est complètement à droite on le voit à
peine sont les capitalisations
boursières il y en a évidemment beaucoup
plus entre les deux mais entre nous et
nos concurrents voyez le petit vie vingt
dix avec le drapeau français ces 15
milliards de capitalisation boursière
ce nice et 156 disney 287 tencent 586
apple de 1812 voilà ça c'est pour vous
montrer que le géant vie 20 10 en
réalité quand on regarde les choses
telles qu'elles sont et pas tel que on
voudrait les présenter c'est un petit
n'a ensuite si vous regardez le tableau
d'après vous vous apercevez que
peut-être en effet nous avons bougé dans
les dernières années et je vais revenir
à votre question évidemment qui est
pourquoi et comment mais vous voyez que
pendant que nos blousons les concurrents
américains qui sont infiniment plus
grands bouge encore plus vite et je
parle pas des concurrents asiatiques qui
aussi bouge extraordinairement vite nous
connaissons bien tencent et un certain
nombre de grands groupes et leurs façons
d'avancer vous voyez la dernière
opération c'est le fameux catalogue mgm
avec tous les films que vous avez vu qui
a été repris par amazon discovery et
puis encore ce matin la reprise de
activision-blizzard
par un grand groupe américain si vous
regardez le tableau d'après
là on parle de canal en france voilà
canal en france c'est le cinquième
acteur du marché voilà nous faisons 6 3%
et encore grâce au succès récents sinon
nous étions un peu au dessous vous voyez
que france tv c'est 28,8 tf1 26 nov l'a6
14,5 si la fusion se fait ils seront à
41 4 mais évidemment si la fusion c'est
on aura l'avantagé de passer à la
quatrième place enfin pour l'instant
nous sommes tout petits à 6,3
sur ce qui fait le plus de papier de ce
que je peux voir c'est le segment de
l'information et là le tableau d'après
est encore intéressant puisqu'on voit en
nombre de téléspectateurs
la taille de ces news qui est la seule
partie information du groupe puisque
dans tout ce que vous avez cités canal
ne fait plus de journaux télévisés ni
aucune des autres chaînes du groupe et
vous voyez que grâce au succès récents
nous sommes à 1 millions en audience
moyenne
bfm et à 2,2 la 6 à 4 la 2 à 7 2 et tf1
9 millions ce sont des fêtes monsieur
rapporteur ce ne sont pas des
et propos le tableau d'après sur la
radio
ça concerne lagardère comme vous savez
nous attendons la commission européenne
est temps que la commission européenne
ne s'est pas prononcée nous ne pouvons
rien faire sur lagardère mais enfin
simplement de savoir que lagardère
aujourd'hui avec leurs pinces et la 8e
place
france inter rtl nrj france bleu rmc
nostalgie info europe 1 monsieur bolloré
je vous interromps deux secondes juste
pour préciser j'ai oublié de le faire
j'aurais dû le dire d'ailleurs que nous
recevrons bien sûr tous les
propriétaires et actionnaires des
différents groupes bien fonctionné on ne
sait ne pas pas que de votre groupe
quand on parle de concentration on parle
aussi d autres mais on voit bien que le
vôtre est en phase ascendante ou en
progression dans la la croissance
vous avez raison de vous entendre bien
sûr mais recevront bien sûr tous les
responsables
si je vous remercie de attendait d'eux
finit juste g33 petit slide pour
terminer
la presse alors la presse nationale
payante quotidienne voyez le tableau que
vous avez sur la partie haute est bien
le groupe n'est aucunement présent ni
vivent un dîner un éventuel lagardère
qui viendrait s'ajouter arrive à nous et
quant à la presse du septième jour qui
est un sujet extrêmement important nous
sommes 1 2 3 4 5 6 le groupe lagardère
et 7e en france
après vous avez l'édition qui est un
sujet dont aussi tout le monde parle et
vous voyez cachette et 3e et editis et
bien nous sommes le 19e acteurs
et puis après vous avez une comparaison
européenne
entre vivendi et bertelsmann qui est un
concurrent allemand et vous voyez que
nous sommes là aussi plus de deux fois
plus petit 8 milliards 7 contre 10 7
milliards 3 et dernier slide je m'arrête
là surprendre et les autres plus tard
s'il ya besoin ça c'est le vix 20-10
d'aujourd'hui et c'est le vix 20-10
d'avant celui qui donc ne posait pas de
problème le vix 20-10 d'aujourd'hui
c'est comme celui d'avant avec canal+
havas ça n'a pas changé
editis s'appelait avant robert laffont
larousse vivent un deuil ou nivelles son
public et c'est la même chose à la place
de gameloft qui avait
activision-blizzard
devenu un géant américain et vous aviez
le groupe express le groupe le point
l'usiné nouvelle des dizaines et des
dizaines de magazines qui était sous le
nom cep vous aviez le groupe de cinéma
et de production audiovisuelle
gc
vous aviez les studio américain
universal vous aviez sfr
l'immense groupe de télécommunications
qui appartient aujourd'hui
patrick graille cegetel pagesjaunes as
well voilà ce que je veux dire en
d'autres termes ce rapporteur c'est que
c'est vrai que nous avons grandi et
c'est vrai que je suis honoré d'être
reçu aujourd'hui au sénat dans le terme
de la concentration puisque quand vous
avez reçue il ya cinq ans c'était parce
que vous êtes tous trouvent très inquiet
enfin certains d'entre vous que canal+
deviennent canal - comme c'était
l'histoire qui était raconté à l'époque
et que au fond les 200 millions financé
le cinéma français allait-il pouvoir
être continuer à financer ou pas est
donc quelque part on sait tard j'allais
dire c'est un compliment qui est fait
quand on s'aperçoit que finalement dans
ces cinq années nous avons progressé
alors pour répondre à votre question
pourquoi c'est uniquement un projet
économique et si vous regardez le slide
numéro 11 c'est à dire 3 slide plus tard
voilà celui ci dans celui ci voit là
vous voyez que dans le monde
le secteur des médias c'est le deuxième
secteur le plus rentable après le luxe
donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent dans les médias et
donc notre intérêt n'est pas politique
n'est pas idéologique c'est un intérêt
purement économique et depuis vingt ans
ce groupe s'est constitué uniquement sur
des questions économiques et vous avez
vu d'ailleurs si c'était politique le
segment de l'information pour nous est
un segment absolument un signifiant à la
fois en chiffre d'affaires chez nous
mais dans le poids du pays c'était le
slide que je vous ai montré en numéro 3
ou 4 où on s'aperçoit que nous sommes
minuscule alors
ça me permet de rebondir
sur ma deuxième question
personne ne conteste des réussites
économiques
personne ici ne jetterai la pierre à 7
réussite économique le sujet est que
nous ne parlons pas de fabrication de
brosses à dents autre chose sans
mépriser aucune activité industrielle
mais nous sommes dans le domaine où se
façonnent l'opinion où la culture vous
en avez parlé de notre pays
vit
avec sa diversité et le domaine de
l'information qui est un domaine
fondamental pour l'exercice de la
démocratie pour que des citoyens
puissent exercer leur
qualité de citoyens c'est à dire être
informer informer des faits de ce qui se
passe pour pouvoir se faire eux mêmes
des opinions et donc c'est pour cela que
j'ai énuméré les activités qui façonnent
cette opinion qui interviennent dans le
domaine où la liberté et d'indépendance
sont fondamentaux pour un pays
démocratique alors vous pouvez minimiser
dire qu'il ya plus gros
quand même c'est la télé qui est très
prescriptrices encore d'opinion
même s'il ya les réseaux sociaux toutes
les études montrent que c'est très
important une chaîne d'information la
radio avec maintenant ce hachette et
europe 1 il y à paris match qui a un
certain poids il y a le jdd mais quand
vous dites c'est pour seulement un
intérêt économique
beaucoup s'interrogent parce que bien
entendu
ce qui fait qu'on parle plus de vous
malgré le fait que vous êtes peut-être
plus petit que d'autres c'est que à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
prises on va dire dans les médias de
votre part il ya une certaine brutalité
a
liquidé détruire des rédactions
ça a été une télé pour faire ses news ça
a été europe 1 et on peut pas dire que
vous avez fait la chasse aux gauchistes
patrick cohen et d'autres où son parti
et puis aujourd'hui paris match le jdd
même les rédactions sofus ou des
communiqués
s'interroge avec ensuite
une ligne donnée
qui idéologiquement très marqué par ce
que depuis la libération c'était des
idéologies qui était plutôt mio au ban
de la république c'est à dire qu'on ne
parlait pas impunément avec des propos
racistes sexistes homophobes et j'en
passe
sur des antennes qui sont pas des
antennes d'opinion puisque la convention
par exemple de ces news avec le csa
dit les choses et qu'il ya une presse
écrite d'opinion mais les conventions de
ce qui est du domaine public
l'autorisation d'émettre par tradition
était pour des chaînes qui assurait
s'engager au pluralisme et c est donc
oui je ma question maintenant est et
est ce que l'intérêt seulement
économique vous n'avez aucune
volonté idéologique et est-ce que vous
n'êtes jamais parce que c'est ça aussi
la garantie qu'il ya des investissements
c'est bien de l'argent peut produire on
peut créer mais vous n'intervenez pas
pour imprimer cette marque dans les
rédactions vous n'exercez pas aussi à
travers cette puissance médiatique
l'intérêt économique
que vous avez par ailleurs ça n'a jamais
été mis au service de vos activités
économiques que j'ai citées par ailleurs
sur la question de l'intervention comme
vous savez monsieur le rapporteur
puisque vous m'avez posé déjà la
question il ya cinq ans sont les deux ou
trois même histoire qui se répète
indéfiniment le crédit mutuel et autres
histoires de la même nature pour
lesquels d'ailleurs maxime saada le
président de canal avait répondu il ya
cinq ans
filmé donc vous pouvez repasser en
allant sur le net ce qu'il avait dit à
l'époque et j'ai vu que dans votre
commission vous aviez reçu récemment le
patron des antennes de ses new skies a
expliqué qu'il n'avait jamais eu
d'intervention de personnes est en tout
cas pas de moi
et qui ne m'avait jamais rencontré une
fois et jamais parlé avec moi
vous savez très bien en tout cas je vous
le répète ce que je vous avais dit à
cinq ans en fait ce hiatus sur les
questions d'interventionnisme on répète
uniquement deux histoires ou trois
histoires qui sont toujours les mêmes
depuis cinq ans et qui sont d'ailleurs
assez ancien
c'est parce que à l'époque canal était
en grande difficulté
canal france perdait 4 à 500 millions
d'euros par an et vive 1,10 à l'époque
était contrôlé essentiellement par des
fonds américains qu'ils n'avaient aucune
envie et aucun intérêt à continuer à
mettre de l'argent de leur poche pour
renflouer canal france et à l'époque il
fallait malheureusement allé faire des
économies
canal a vécu très bien quand il était en
monopole et malheureusement quand des
grands gafa sont arrivés quand des
grands groupes de sport sont arrivés
canal s'est retrouvé plus en difficulté
wa ma famille joue les 10 a été très
riche et puis un moment et se retrouve
en difficulté il a fallu faire des
économies et il a fallu faire des
économies chez canal et celui qui est
allé qui a été envoyée c'est moi ce qui
était mon rôle se pense et c'est naturel
je voulais dit à l'époque que j'ai été
le bouc émissaire parce que quand vous
voulez faire des économies aux gens
qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire ils vont pas
dire c'est affreux on fait des économies
10 d'affreux il intervient dans les
contenus sans en apporter aucun élément
d'ailleurs et je m'amusais en voyant le
festival de cannes pierre lescure lui
même a dit il ya quelques jours
canal avant c'était 500 personnes
pendant quinze jours à cannes dont canal
vraiment ne peut plus 500 personnes de
canal à cannes c'était vrai 2000 euros
par jour 500 personnes 1 million un
million x 15 égale 15 millions et il
fallait remonter comme ça 400 millions
et donc voilà pourquoi est-ce que tout
ceci est venu à quel moment tout ceci
est venu pourquoi tout ceci est venu
c'est parce qu'en effet on a été obligé
de faire des économies l'histoire d'i
télé dont vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
i télé a englouti 400 millions d'euros
au cours de son existence 400 millions
d'euros au cours de son existence
il fallait à un moment mettre fin à ceux
ci là où je ne partage pas du tout ce
que vous dites c'est quand vous dites
nous avons détruit non nous avons
construit quand je suis arrivé chez
canal d'ailleurs j'ai dit je ne suis pas
là la cause de vos problèmes je suis là
conséquences de vos problèmes et
peut-être la solution
et quand on regarde tout ça au fond
qu'est ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que les 8000 personnes de canal
continue à travailler c'est que si vous
regardez ce que c'est que les chiffres
de viviers de canal vous le verrez dans
les slides c'est 300 millions
d'obligations cinéma audiovisuel chaque
année 500 millions investis dans le
cinéma français et européen chaque année
75 millions de redevances aux sociétés
d'auteurs chaque année c'est le slide 12
2 milliards et demi d'impôts payés entre
17 et 21 donc si vous voulez je pense
que d'être le bouc émissaire je vous
avais dit pas à l'époque bouc émissaire
vous avez dit paratonnerre pourrait tout
à fait exact veulent l'assument
volontiers c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est de savoir est ce que canal a
réussi à se sortir de toutes ces
questions oui est ce qu'il a réussi à
s'internationaliser parce que le
problème c'est pas seulement d'avoir la
culture française avoir la culture
européenne
c'est de savoir est ce qu'on est capable
de l'internationaliser et la force du
groupe vivendi canal à la différence de
ses collègues français c'est que c'est
le seul groupe qui s'est vraiment
développée à l'international quand vous
regardez d'ailleurs les chiffres de
canal et ou de vie 20 10 dans les
différents métiers l'essentiel est fait
en permettant de rayonner aux artistes
extérieurs je reviendrai maintenant sur
un des points des questions que vous
avez soulevés qui concerne en effet ce
ne sont pas des brosses à dents c'est ça
m'a pas échappé que ce sont pas des
brosses à dents ou des automobiles les
créateurs de contenus sont des gens
extraordinairement sensible par nature
c'est vrai pour légende havas c'est vrai
pour les gens de la télévision chez
canal et c'est vrai pour l'édition ma
mère a été pendant 50 ans lectrice chez
gallimard donc est rapportée à la maison
les livres qu'il faut plutôt les
manuscrits qu'elle lisait et j'ai
rencontré j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer d'état d'auteur de toutes
sortes donc je sais très bien ce que
sont les journalistes les créatifs nous
n'avons pas détruit nous avons
reconstruit et nous avons aujourd'hui
120 je crois ou 130 journalistes carte
de presse a dit thomas boddaert je crois
chez ces news dont
me fait faire des économies est en effet
un moment pénible j'espère que ça ne
nous est pas arrivé moi ça m'est arrivé
je peux vous dire que c'est un
changement quand tout d'un coup on vous
annonce que ce qui faisait votre
monopôle ou ce qu'il faisait votre
richesse vous ne l'avez plus mais vous
avez deux solutions en face de ça la
première c'est de se laisser aller et
puis de faire faillite et puis la
deuxième c'est de reprendre de choisir
des gens de pousser à travailler
ensemble
d'essayer de rayonner à l'international
parce que c'est là vous frotter aux
concurrents réels et puis c'est de
donner les moyens d'avancer sur le long
terme et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je
vous remercie de l'avoir reconnu tout à
l'heure notre groupe a réussi à se
redresser mais je re continue à vous
dire que c'est un groupe encore petit il
n'en reste pas moins que il n'ya aucune
idéologie politique vous avez parlé de
la libération d'abord dans mon adn la
seule chose qu'on peut dire en dehors du
fait que j'ai toujours dit que j'étais
démocrate chrétien c'est la liberté
voilà ma famille s'est battue
vous parliez de l'après guerre mon père
était dans la résistance d'hier et il
était de la classe 22e alors se
soustraire au st lô à l'époque c'était
un peu obligatoire le 6 juin 44 au
débarquement ils nient avec 177 français
général de gaulle a été prévu prévenu la
veille il a dit je veux absolument que
soient des français sur tille a dit
écoutez je crois pas qu'ils aient des
françaises le pas sur il ya 350 milles
bercy qui débarque il y en a avec 177
sous les ordres de lord lovât dont deux
de ma famille ma grand mère était au
service action pendant des dizaines
d'années en particulier pendant la
guerre et j'ai un autre oncle dans
normandie niemen dont je crois pas que
je vais un adn qui ne permettent pas
dire que je n'aime pas passionnément mon
pays ou que je n'aime pas passionnément
la démocratie j'aime les deux mais je
crois que c'est un peu court d'aller
ressortir des histoires pour lesquels
d'ailleurs on vous a répondu les
personnes adéquates vous ont répondu et
je crois que vous réentendez maxime
saada bientôt et vous avez entendu
thomas beau dr il ya quelques temps j'ai
même vu dans vos auditions à monsieur
que je ne connais pas très gentil
visiblement monsieur vire qui a dit mais
monsieur bolloré n'est jamais intervenu
donc je crois qu'il faut garder les
choses telles qu'elles sont en réalité
ils vendent y est un groupe qui est
capable peut-être ce type peut-être tout
cas moi ce sera plus moi puisque moi
comme vous savez mon délai de péremption
arrivent à échéance et quand nous allons
fêter le bicentenaire du groupe le 17
février prochain les équipes dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure prennent la suite
mais la question c'est de savoir est ce
que ce groupe est capable d'aller faire
rayonner la culture française et
européenne dans le monde ou pas et moi
je crois que le rayonnement
l'aide aux créateurs le soutien aux
journalistes le soutien au dirigeant
c'est compatible avec la réussite
économique et je crois que l'un vers ce
n'est pas compatible donc je vais je
vais être prêt si vous vous l'aurez
justement parce que c'est ça c'est
intéressant qu'il y ait une suite ont
effectivement vous êtes déjà venu devant
le sénat à l'époque j'avais relayer
la sphère d'un documentaire qui vous
avez des plus de tristan valek qui
depuis d'ailleurs a été couronnée par le
célèbre prix albert londres
un documentaire qui s'appelait vincent
bolloré un ami qui vous veut du bien et
qui mettait en accusation des activités
que vous aviez en afrique à travers
notamment cette histoire
de d'enfants qui travaillent sur les
plantations et vous avait réfuté
d'ailleurs vous m'aviez dit je vais
attaquer en justice parce que c'est faux
vous avez
attaqué en justice vous avez même
demandé 50 millions c'est pas rien
et ça fait peur en tous les cas j'ai vu
que les jugements et le jugement en
appel
vous on
retourne et disons-le affaire puisque
vous êtes
vous dit que vous avez
dégénérer on abus de droit d'ester en
justice et que le montant demandé est
exorbitant et vous avez vous été
condamnée à dix mille euros à verser au
groupe de télévision france télévisions
qui avait diffusé ce documentaire vous
confirmez
quand je confirme que nous n'avons
jamais eu ni moi ni aucun cadre ni aucun
employé du groupe bolloré dans les
plantations en afrique ces panneaux de
la même façon qu'il ya des cambodgiens
qui viennent faire un procès en disant à
la compagnie du cambodge vous occuper
nos terres y'a pas terrain dans la
compagnie du cambodge donc pardonnez moi
de vous dire le procès a relaxé de façon
générale parce qu'ils étaient entre
guillemets de bonne foi mais ça
n'empêche pas que ces plantations ne
nous ont jamais appartenu et que le
jeune homme qui soi-disant avait 14 ans
et qui avait trois ou quatre ans de plus
c'est pas n'a jamais non mais n'a jamais
travaillé pour moi moi je veux bien est
accusé des choses mais j'ai commise j'ai
zéro sur ne je ne suis pas parfait mais
j'assume et je ne me des repas oui mais
là il s'agit en effet à nouveau d'un
sujet d' amalgame c'est à dire qu'on dit
vous gérez déportation non nous ne
gérons pas des plantations ya un groupe
belge qui s'appelle fabry qui est
majoritaire dans ses plantations plus 90
ans nous en avons hérité d'une
participation quand nous avons fusionné
avec le crip rivaux et nous n'avons
jamais opérée dans ses plantations je
vous dis les choses telles qu'elles sont
je ne me dérobe pas bien donc
ici on n'est pas dans un tribunal moi
j'ai vu des choses et je me souviens
nous avait dit que vous attaquerons en
justice pour m'avait demandé hier à la
justice que vous venez de me dire la
justice a répondu que c'était une
procédure abusive et vous a condamné
vous pour procédure abusive pas parce
que effectivement
il y à un des sujets de la pression sur
l'information ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle les procédures maillon on
demande des sommes si exorbitantes que
ça fait que des producteurs souvent ne
veulent pas prendre le risque d'
enquêter ou d'aller trop en avant sur un
centre de choses parce que ils
pourraient se retrouver sur la paille
s'il était condamné donc vous avez fait
trois procédures de ce type que vous
avez perdu en justice et on vous
reproche souvent sur vos activités
effectivement d'empêcher une certaine
liberté d'enquêter et de faire des
reportages je veux finir avec ma
dernière question parce que là
franchement
vous n'avez pas répondu du tout sur la
connotation
politique et idéologique certains vont
plus loin j'ai lu beaucoup et d'hommes y
compris l'ancien président de la
république qui a qui dit que vous vous
avez fabriqué un candidat à la
présidentielle quand il a été
renvoyé
2012 je crois ni télé vous avez dit on
ont piqué une colère noire et il est
revenu assez fortement sur le paysage
personne ne croit que vous n'y êtes pour
rien dans sa présence dans votre volonté
qu'ils puissent avoir pignon sur rue sur
l'antenne de ses news et personne ne
pense qu'il n'y a aucune connotation
idéologique aux politiques aux médias
que vous prenez que vous saisissez et
qu'il n'y a pas de changement assez
important de la ligne éditoriale et des
rédactions dans ces médias quand
vous en prenez le contrôle donc vous
vous définissez comme démocrate chrétien
est ce que le
racisme le négationnisme sont des
valeurs démocrates chrétiennes je ne
crois pas et je voulais vous demander si
c'est à votre insu qu'une telle ligne
éditoriale s'impose dans les médias que
vous contrôlez y compris les sommes que
vous mettez c'est quand même vous qui
les mettait à la place où les femmes
leur passé et leur revendications
idéologiques politiques sont marqués
nettement souvent à l'extrême droite
vous n'y êtes pour rien écoutez je pense
que vous prenez des petits bouts de
choses vous les mettez ensemble pour
essayer de faire une histoire on
pourrait par exemple dire que je suis
déconstructionniste ok vous avez vu la
polémique sur yale yale c'est le petit
robert le petit robert c'est editis
editis et vincent bolloré dont vincent
bolloré est déconstructionniste alors
vous avez des dizaines de milliers
d'heures sur nos programmes voilà et
quant à zemmour pardonnez moi mais il
est y publier des livres à des centaines
de milliers d'exemplaires bien avant
qu'il ne revienne sur ses news je vous
rappelle qu'il est sur le figaro je vous
rappelle qu'il est sur l'a6 et comme par
hasard ces quantités sur ces news que
savons problème mais je redis il ya
tellement de courant de pensée dans nos
livres dans nos émissions moi je
personne ne pensait personne ne savait
qu'ils allaient de président de la
république franchement c'est pas
raisonnable
et celles rapportées chez moi je
voudrais quand même un peu éclairé au
delà de la question la personne en
question le rôle de l'actionnaire par
rapport à aux médias c'est un point qui
nous concerne sur cette commission
denquête solaire à concentration vous
aviez dit en 2016 dont j'ai réécouté la
l'audition
vous aviez eu ici même au sénat pour
définir justement ce rôle qui était le
vôtre en tant qu'actionnaire principal
et vous aviez dit précisément tu restes
vous avez repris un peu les mêmes termes
dans votre propos liminaire le rôle de
l'actionnaire il consiste à fixer un cap
a nommé des équipes a parlé avec elle
pour s'assurer qu'elles soient suivies
qu'elles suivent toujours ce cap et à
répondre à leurs questions
et les termes précis que vous aviez
utilisé à l'époque jusqu'où ça va la
définition de ce cap quand il s'agit
d'un média qu'est ce que ça va jusqu'à
définir la ligne éditoriale et de
recrutement des équipes quand il s'agit
aussi d'un média jusqu'où ça va s que ça
va jusqu'au choix des éditorialistes des
principaux journalistes
évidemment ce sont les dirigeants que je
choisis mes depuis 40 ans le succès de
ce groupe a été de faire des repérages
de talent alors évidemment maintenant on
dit zemmour mais on pourrait dire yves
calvi j'ai passé du temps avec il qu'à
venise calvi qui est venu d'ailleurs sur
le groupe canal clé passer du temps avec
bono le chanteur qui est venu c'est
universe hall j'ai passé du temps avec
marc levy
je passe du temps avec bernard henri
lévy mon travail consiste en effet à fit
enfin consistait puisque maintenant je
ne suis plus que conseil et bientôt plus
rien mais mon travail consistait pour
l'essentiel à fixer des caps à choisir
des gens et à les laisser travailler et
vous connaissez se croient les
dirigeants du groupe vivendi canal sont
des gens qui ont des personnalités de
l'autorité des compétences ils sont
d'ailleurs pénalement responsable de ce
qui se passe dans leurs médias donc je
ne vois pas comment on pourrait leur
imposer quoi que ce soit et j'observe
que dans toutes les commissions vous
avez tenu jusqu'à présent toutes les
personnes que vous avez interrogé aucune
n'a dit que j'étais intervenu
personnellement sur quoi que ce soit et
je vous redis le groupe est tellement
vaste on peut dire une chose et son
contraire sur mes amis politiques si on
commence à disséquer je vous ai donné
l'exemple duels mais je pourrais vous
donner les tableaux des exemples de gens
qui est dire et rédige est dite ou parle
sur nos antennes et je ne peux en aucune
façon est responsable de ça
et je trouve qu'au contraire et on vous
l'a dit toutes les expressions sont sur
les différentes antennes mais enfin en
réalité on fait un monde si on veut bien
repasser le slide qui montre ce que nous
sommes en termes de
d'audience sur le plan des
des émissions d'information qui est
absolument risible c'est tout petit
petit parce qu'en vérité sur canal les
vrais sujets c'est le sport
pardonnez moi je ne me retrouve pas et
je vais finir par le retrouver quelques
pas voilà
je ne sais plus leucate voilà non ça
c'est europe il y en avait un autre
juste avant peut-être sur le segment de
l'information voilà après 4 l'a4 non il
y en avait encore un plus petit en terme
à la ccin segment de l'information tv
vous voyez on est à 1 par rapport à 9 à
7 à 4 donc on est tout petit en réalité
et donc l'essentiel de canal qu'est ce
que c'est c'est le cinéma c'est le sport
et c'est les séries
vous avez sans la vérité vous avez tout
à fait raison nous rappeler les parts
d'audience c'est à dire j'ai pris soin
aussi dans mon propos introductifs de
les rappeler néanmoins il ya quand même
un sujet sur sur ces news et sur la
télévision en général c'est que jusqu'à
présent il n'y a pas de télé d'opinion
la télévision française était
contrairement à la presse qui est basée
sur une presse d'opinion historiquement
elle a été faite comme ça la télévision
notamment parce que les les droits des
maîtres sont en nombre limité n'a pas
été construite sur un schéma de de télé
d'opinion
certain nombre d'observateurs des médias
constate que la chaîne ses news je crois
que
nombreux à porter ce constat la chaîne
ces news n'est pas loin d'être une télé
d'opinion est ce que vous partagez ce
constat ecoutez-moi fait vue l'audition
de thomas boddaert qui en est le patron
qui dit que c'est une chaîne de débat et
vous aurez maxime saada qui viendra je
crois à plélo puis fontaine quel
président de vivendi ils auraient dû
prendre ma place ailleurs et vous verrez
que voilà personne n'a l'ambition ou
l'intention ou l'erreur d'essayer de
faire des chaînes d'opinion c'est pas
dans l'objectif du groupe vivendi canal
ça n'a pas d'importance ça n'a pas
d'intérêt nous sommes là pour être
sur la liberté de l'expression et nous
sommes là pour l'essentiel pour
permettre à nos clients qui veulent voir
sur canal du sport du cinéma et des
séries de leur donner le mieux de ce
qu'on peut donner dans ce domaine
monsieur année dernière question
une rame harper une remarque monsieur
zemmour lui même dans son livre dit que
c'est lui que c'est vous pardon qui a
l'avait convaincu de rejoindre la chaîne
il était déjà d'ailleurs condamné
pour des propos et encore hier d'autres
propos donc il dit lui dans son livre
que c'est vous qui l'avait convaincu de
venir comme je vous ai dit tu râles à
l'heure je rencontre beaucoup de gens
j'essaie de venir faire venir beaucoup
de gens et malheureusement pour moi ou
heureusement pour moi je ne sais pas
monsieur zemmour était très connu bien
avant qu'il ne me rends compte pour la
première fois
ils vendaient des centaines de milliers
de livres il est sur les autres chaînes
ça ne posait aucun problème est ce que
savait très bien c'est venu pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées tout à l'heure
est ce que vous vous souhaiteriez que
eric zemmour s'il n'est pas élu
président de la république revienne sur
ses news mais attendez c'est pas moi
pardonnez moi je suis embêté je n'ai pas
le pouvoir de nommer qui que ce soit
l'inter déchets voilà je peux proposer
je peux donner mon avis je peux dire ne
pensez vous pas que voilà et si
quelqu'un n'a pas envie de le faire il
le fait pas et j'ai quatre cinq six sept
personnes qui sont toutes connues et
reconnues pour leurs forces que si elle
considère c'est pas bon pour le groupe
ne le ferons pas donc ma capacité
personnelle allait imposer des choses et
pas très importante contrairement à ce
que vous pensez
j'aurai mon lyonnais
merci président bonjour monsieur bolloré
le président la faune commencer par cela
il disait que votre audition devant la
commission denquête était
particulièrement médiatique je n'aurais
pas faire de jeu de mots mais je crois
que nous battons des records d'audience
grâce à vous
et ce matin en lisant l'opinion je
voyais
concentration dans l'édition sous la
plume de catherine boulay bolloré sur le
gril des sénateurs donc juste dire et
tout à fait de façon personnelle que
nous sommes ici sachant le sérieux des
travaux du sénat et des commission
denquête sous la responsabilité de
laurent laffont sommes d'ici pour
d'abord comprendre analyser et cette
compréhension et cette analyse
nourrissent ensuite l'écriture d'une loi
pour l'adapter à la société actuelle
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
commencé votre carrière professionnelle
à l'âge de 18 ans en 1970 à l'union
européenne industrielle et financière
c'est exact c'est assez actuelle
et puis un demi-siècle s'en est suivie
d'une trajectoire exceptionnelle vous
l'avez dit d'une réussite familiale
qui inspire dans notre pays
deux choses où le respect et
l'admiration
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on crée de
la richesse de l'emploi et du
sacro-saint pouvoir d'achat ou alors du
rejet de la suspicion parce que dans
notre beau pays la réussite des plaies
alors moi ce que je ce que je voudrais
comprendre pour quelqu'un qui est assez
visionnaire qu'on vous apprécie ou pas
mais personne ne peut vous daignez ce
cette qualité d'être visionnaire puisque
vous l'avez dit vous avez commencé dans
les médias dans les années 2000 donc ça
fait déjà plus de 20 ans à votre avis et
ça sera ma question
comment peut-on concilier à notre époque
la nécessaire recomposition du marché
des médias
avec la non moins nécessaire
préservation du flux réalisme qui fait
vivre notre démocratie
moi personnellement je trouve qu'il ya
un grand pluralisme aujourd'hui est que
si on veut aller écouter les uns ou les
autres on est capable de le retrouver le
vrai danger ce sont les gaffes à qui son
vous l'avez vu des poids considérable
qui passe à travers des tuyaux non
contrôlée non contrôlable
et moi je crois que la vraie question
est de savoir est ce que on est capable
tout en permettant à des médias de se
développer
de leur faire gagner de l'argent tout en
restant dans la pluralité moi je crois
que c'est possible
et c'est vrai que
vous avez un sujet compliqué parce que
la concentration des médias forcément
pour ce problème mais la taille des
concurrents que nous avons
pose aussi problème et vous avez en
effet un sujet complexe à régler nous
vous savez ça fait je les dis dans trois
semaines ça fera deux cents ans que le
groupe existe donc nous avons connu nous
aurons connu trois rois un empereur 26
président de la république donc on
s'adaptera
mais
c'est un sujet complexe parce que je
peux vous dire que de ma petite fenêtre
comment faire coup pour que vive indique
annales malgré les critiques et le reste
et je redis je fais le paratonnerre avec
plaisir c'est mon travail sais pas
comment ils vont faire après mais enfin
bon je resterai peut-être quand même en
paratonnerre apparent
c'est compliqué parce que la taille est
énorme quand vous voyez arriver netflix
voyez canal c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
mal travaillé qui sont trouvés devant
des difficultés ils sont trouvés devant
un petit vendeur de tee loueur de
cassettes qui tout d'un coup est devenu
un groupe à 500 milliards ou 400
milliards de capitalisation et qui
finalement fait des séries en payant
double la vraie question c'est est-ce
qu'à la fin une fois qu'il aura les x
millions de clients française qui
continuera à faire ou pas la place pour
la culture de notre pays c'est ça la
vraie question est quand vous avez quand
même des entrepreneurs qui sont dans ce
pays
il ya plus de chances qu'ils défendent
la culture de leur pays que quand c'est
les entrepreneurs de l'étranger et
j'allais même dire que dans tous les
secteurs industriels quand vous avez un
groupe français s'ils rencontrent des
difficultés il gardera ses usines en
france mais si c'est un groupe étranger
il fermera ses usines en france donc
vous avez une difficile mission
puisqu'il faut à la fois aider
des gens à se développer et éviter
qu'ils aient une concentration trop
forte je peux pas répondre à cette
question malheureusement gibbons aux
propos très aimable en tout cas merci
monsieur le président monsieur bolloré
les quinze jours monsieur remercier pour
la clarté de vos réponses
permettez moi tout d'abord de revenir
sur les questions de david assouline
qu'est ce qui vous attire vers les
médias parce que vous l'avez dit c'est
la rentabilité si bien compris dans
votre dans les propos mais enfin c'est
quand même un milieu où depuis que vous
êtes investi vous avez pris quand même
beaucoup de coups est ce qu'il n'a pas
fait des effets collatéraux sur les
autres activités de votre groupe ça
c'est ma peau ma requête sur la deuxième
justement quand on a un groupe comme le
vôtre et y avoir certaines passerelle
vous êtes propriétaire de havas qui
met en place des programmes
publicitaires qui conçoit certaines
publicités qui ensuite sont achetés par
des médias est-ce que là il n'y a pas
forcément on n'est pas tenté d'aller
toujours vers les médias qui
appartiennent au même groupe
et puis juste pour revenir aussi sur
sujets abordés par davidas weeds on a
auditionné il ya quelques jours le
directeur général de reporters sans
frontières
qui nous a parlé à sa façon
de votre personne et je voulais savoir
dans les propos que l'on vous reproche
il ya une gestion assez brutale dans vos
affaires est ce que vous les assumez
merci monsieur bolloré merci beaucoup
n'ont écouté je pense pas qu'ils aient
de gestion brutale il ya simplement
le courage de dire les choses
et le courage quand elles sont graves
j'ai évoqué le cas de canal tout à
l'heure où de itélé de prendre des
mesures
quand vous êtes malade
vous avez des gens autour de vous qui
vous disent t'inquiète pas ça n'a aucune
importance continue et puis à un moment
vous retrouvez avec une situation qui a
empiré ou alors vous avez
quelqu'un qui vous dit voilà tu as une
maladie il faut la regarder va passer un
examen et on prendra les mesures pour la
réparer si c'est ça que vous appelez
brutale oui je suis brutale parce que
c'est brutal de dire la vérité c'était
brutal de dire à canal ça perd 400
millions mais vous savez les coûts
pardon je sais que vous êtes pris par le
temps mais si vous aviez deux minutes
j'ai mis
quelques minutes de film qui sont
passées pendant que j'étais président
chez canal
et actif à l'époque puisque après j'ai
laissé la présidence à un maxime saada
et à jean christophe thiery mais pendant
que j'étais actif il ya un petit film si
vous voulez bien le passé il y en a pour
deux minutes qui vous montrera ce qui se
passait chez canal pendant que j'y étais
et qui montrera que tout ça ce que je
vous propose monsieur bolloré c'est de
le passer à la phase est mobile et de
nombreuses questions va monsieur gilles
ans comme un griot et quant aux coûts
c'est vrai qu'ils sont élevés c'est pour
ça que je dis que je fais paratonnerre
mais je pense qu'il ya une grande
satisfaction dans les équipes de savoir
que maintenant le groupe gagne de
l'argent de savoir que maintenant la
situation est rétablie on peut investir
à l'étranger
je crois que les gens de canal était
très très très inquiet à l'époque et je
pense qu'en effet c'est des coups c'est
pas bon pour le moral quand je suis
arrivé d'ailleurs à la tête de vivendi
on m'a dit mais surtout tu t'assois tu
prends la cave à cigares tu fais rien du
tout et attend que ça passe et tu
profites
est-ce que c'est l'adn dont je parlais
tout à l'heure ma maîtresse quand
j'étais en septième un avait envoyé un
bulletin de consignes avec marc et à mes
parents vincent se mêle de tout il n'a
plus qu'à prendre ma place
je sais pas c'est peut-être comme ça
mais en tout cas si vous voulez c'est à
la fois pénible mais d'un autre côté le
plaisir du travail accompli la
satisfaction de voir les 80000 personnes
rien que cinéma français dont on parlait
il ya cinq ans cinéma français
maintenant on a plus d'inquiétudes sur
canal alors après est ce que le cinéma
français préfèrent amazon est prêt fermé
deux flics ça c'est son choix mais en
tout cas on ne lui a pas retirer la
carte amal et je pense que c'est bien ce
qui a été fait par un autre puits
fontaines
chez vivendi par maxime saada et toutes
les équipes chez canal et sa récompense
des coûts prix je les trouve évidemment
souvent injuste mais bon
vous n'avez pas répondu à la question
michel logis sur sur les liens entre les
entreprises notamment par rapport à
havas parce que je crois que ça
correspond quand même à un avis une
remarque faite par l'autorité des
marchés financiers dans son rapport 2010
9 le fait que l'étanchéité entre les
différents des éléments de du groupe
notamment
damas avec les éditeurs n'est pas
assurée et que du coup il peut y avoir
un distorsion par rapport à des
concurrents écoutez je ne le crois pas
monsieur le président parce que havas ne
fait que prendre la publicité de ses
clients pour la mettre sur des médias
sylvain s'amuser à les mettre la
publicité
sur ses propres médias ça se verrait
très vite il y aurait un problème mais
je rappelle simplement une chose canal+
le groupe je veux pas dire de bêtises je
crois que ces quatre milliards et demi
de chiffre d'affaires ou cinq milliards
de livres 5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
sur les 5 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires la totalité de la publicité
sur canal c'est 100 millions c'est à
dire que ces 2 % donc même à 20
s'amuserait ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas parce qu'il ya des murailles de
chine ça n'aurait pas de conséquence ni
pour l'un ni pour l'autre
nick de barco merci
monsieur bolloré voilà dans vos propos
introductif vous avez exprimé
l'intention de faire rayonner la culture
française face à la culture asiatique
américaine ce sont des intentions très
louable voilà mais parallèlement il faut
comprendre l'inquiétude concernant vos
acquisitions dans le domaine des médias
et de l'édition je prends l'exemple du
slide de numéro 6 avec le journal du
dimanche
ce lundi 14 janvier la rédaction du jdd
a exprimé ses craintes de devenir je
cite un vulgaire médias d'opinion comme
ses news suite à la nomination comme
directeur général jérôme béglé
chroniqueur régulier de ses news la
rédaction du jdd très inquiète pour son
indépendance et prend en exemple ce qui
s'est passé à europe 1 avez-vous des
réponses apportées à la rédaction du jdd
première question excusez moi j'ai une
deuxième très courte le candidat eric
zemmour annonce vouloir démanteler le
service public france télé et radio
france partagez vous ces propos c'est
bref
écouter sur zemmour à nouveau
franchement je n'ai pas plus de
responsabilités de poids sur lui que
l'on à nicolas de tavernot
le patron propriétaire du figaro les
dassault monsieur edelstenne j'ai vu
qu'ils me téléphonait tous les jours
qu'on déjeuner tous les mois que j'ai
déjeuné qu'une seule fois avec lui qui
est la fois en effet où on lui a proposé
de rejoindre ses news mais là aussi si
on commence à dire attendez c'est pas
vrai on va dire qu'on fait des procès
bâillon si on commence à dire donc voilà
sur zemmour franchement eric zemmour
était a le droit de s'exprimer il fait
ce qu'il veut et son programme ne me
regarde pas je n'ai jamais fait de
politique je ne ferai jamais de
politique en ce qui concerne le journal
du dimanche je n'ai aucune
responsabilité dans le journal du
dimanche je n'ai pas nommer personne et
c'est arnaud lagardère qui gère son
groupe
mais évidemment il ya une telle pression
qui est fait par les médias en faisant
vincent bolloré pouvant table le
boogeyman d'épouvantail que évidemment
je vais normal que les journal du
dimanche faisait peur même semble
connaître je les connais pas mais avec
ce qu'on écrit c'est naturel qu'ils
aient peur
donc s'il avait envie de me voir mais je
n'ai aucun rôle pour les voir ils
verraient que je suis un garçon tout à
fait normal et qu'ils ont pas se sentir
menacé c'est un avis personnel et line
renaud garabédian et pardon sus tout
monsieur peillon et arnaud puyfontaine
qui est le vrai président de bionis et
du président directeur du lundi donc je
suis très honorée d'être la rue est un
garçon qui connaît par coeur la presse
tous les gens de la presse les cônes le
connaissent et savent que c'est un
garçon tout à fait remarquable donc si
un jour il devait y avoir je dis bien si
un jour il devait y avoir une
autorisation de bruxelles est un lien
entre le groupe lagardère et leur hobby
20 10 je suis sûr que tout ça se
passerait très bien comme ça se passe
très bien dans les autres magazines du
groupe des vingt dix mon avis pardon
monsieur faisait donne un jour est venue
de renault garabédian merci monsieur le
président monsieur bolloré nous avons
auditionné en début de semaine un
professeur d'université historien des
médias qui nous a indiqué que la
concentration n'était pas un problème
démocratique mais une question
économique
qu'il n'y avait pas de rapport entre
concentration et pluralisme et qu'au
contraire en 40 ans les supports de
diffusion avait énormément augmenté
s'étaient multipliées pourtant 16 % des
français seulement font confiance aux
journalistes
qu'en pensez vous
j'ai pas d'idée malheureusement madame
la sénatrice je ne suis pas du tout dans
compétents dans ces matières
je ne sais pas je pense que je vous dis
il est possible de se renseigner il est
possible de lire il est possible
d'écouter la télévision il est possible
de regarder sur le net des informations
tellement diverse
que les gens sont des idées voilà moi je
n'ai pas d'opinion à exprimer et
malheureusement je vous le disais tout à
l'heure votre commission c'est compliqué
parce que je ne sais pas comment régler
ces questions
je ne sais pas comment régler ces
questions nous en tout cas à nouveau
l'essentiel de la vie du groupe vivendi
canal à la télévision c'est le cinéma le
sport et les séries je redis à ou pour
enlever le fantasme de du projet
politique
on a un truc insignifiant en termes de
d'outils d'information d'outil de
propagande si on voulait faire de la
propagande c'est infinitésimal
si on avait vraiment eu un projet
politique c'est sans doute pas
d'ailleurs canal dans lequel on serait
allé ou en tout cas pas comme ça on
serait allés plutôt sur l'a6 ou sur des
des opérations beaucoup plus ouverte
nous nous sommes spécialisés
dans ses contenus et en plus ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'international je
voulais dit tout à l'heure
l'essentiel de canal aujourd'hui son
développement se fait à l'international
on a plus de 20 millions d'abonnés dont
plus de la moitié maintenant sont à
l'international et si vous me re
convoquer dans cinq ans vous avez aucune
chance parce que je serai gâteux
ben vous verrez qu'il y aura au 30
millions d'abonnés sur canal et il y en
aura 20 millions à l'international
donc le sujet politique n'est pas à
l'intérieur de canal un sujet essentiel
je suis lien barge ton pied derrière son
écran
j'ai mis un large temps
oui
le voyons julien oui
ce que vous m'entendez oui très bien
m'entendez oui bonsoir
bonsoir vincent bolloré julien bargeton
sénateur de paris mon soir vincent
bonsoir alors j'ai une question qui
prolonge celle qui a été posée notamment
par michel laugier et puis également le
le président sur le lien avec havas
quand même puisque vous nous avez dit
qu' il n'y avait pas de lien mais
lorsque vous avez pris la tête de
vivendi lors de l'assemblée générale du
24 juin 2014 vous avez affiché votre
volonté de transformer cette holding
financière en groupe industriel intégré
dans les contenus il semblerait que
lorsque havas media que vous contrôlez
recommande un annonceur de choisir un
média pour diffuser ses publicités les
chaînes du groupe canal+ que vous
contrôlez également soit favorisée en
2018 je reconnais ce sont des chiffres
un peu anciens donc peut-être que vous
allez me répondre ces chaînes ont par
exemple représenté 12 1% des espaces
publicitaires achetés par havas alors
qu'elles n'ont pesé que 9% chez les
autres agences concurrentes il ya donc
une discordance 23.1 aussi pouvez vous
nous dire si des consignes ont déjà été
données chez havas media pour favoriser
les chaînes du groupe canal+ sinon
comment expliquer cette différence par
rapport aux autres agences et ont elles
été corrigé depuis 2018 deuxième
question c'est news a reçu le 3 décembre
une mise en demeure du csa relative à l'
équilibre des opinions notamment avec
l'arrêt de la diffusion a jugé nocturne
pour les temps de parole de l'exécutif
ainsi que ceux de l efi et donc le csa a
réagi bhl 3 décembre paru mise en
demeure pouvez-vous nous garantir que
les mesures ont été prises pour mettre
fin à ces pratiques et que désormais le
rééquilibrage a été opéré le remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur alors sur la
deuxième question v aucun pouvoir pour
dire à quiconque de rééquilibrer mais
j'ai entendu thomas boddaert qui a
expliqué que ce n'était qu'une mise en
demeure préventif et que depuis les
équilibres avait été maintenu d'ailleurs
sur une règle du jeu qu'il ne
connaissait pas qui était le distinguo
entre le jour et la nuit mais enfin ils
se sont remis en ordre et à ma
connaissance je vois pas de raison
pourquoi ces dirigeants qui risqueraient
des sanctions et donc leur place
risquerait de faire des choses qui sont
pas conforme à la légalité sur havas je
n'en suis plus président depuis beaucoup
d'années et vous pouvez en recevoir les
dirigeants mais c'est un vieux débat sur
les 12 9% 6% il ya ceux qui disent que
publicis comme c'est notre concurrent
fait exprès de pas donner à canal
et que havas donne un peu plus voilà
mais je redis sur canal 5 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires et donc les 3% de
plus de havas s'est peut-être un million
deux donc si vous voulez pardonnez moi
je crois qu'aucune consigne
anormale ne puisse être donnée pour des
sommes aussi risible donc je ne le crois
pas du tout mais interrogé les gens
d'arras si vous le souhaitez vous verrez
qu'il ya des murailles de chine et que
tous les grands groupes de publicité
dans le monde nous ne sommes que cinq ou
six dans le monde il n'y en a cinq ou
six dans le monde font bien attention
parce que sinon ils perdraient leurs
clients et qu' ils le donnent de la
publicité que dans les endroits où il ya
évidemment des tarifs favorables et un
intérêt pour leurs clients
là où par contre si motorisée de
compléter la question
on est en effet un groupe industriel
intégré mais avec havas était pas dans
ce cadre là c'était dans le cadre de la
création en fait les films duré trois
heures du temps du docteur jivago puis
ensuite une heure et demie à deux heures
et puis ensuite on est passé à des
séries de 20 minutes et beaucoup de gens
pensent que l'accélération des contenus
et l'intérêt des gens pour voir des
contenus de plus en plus rapidement va
faire que la durée des films qui sont
gardés peut se réduire or qui sont les
gens qui font les films les plus courts
et les plus efficaces sont les
publicitaires et ça c'est un sujet pour
le futur vous avez d'ailleurs les
podcasts qui sont des petits éléments
qui sont un peu plus court et c'était
dans cet esprit là que j'avais dit il
faudrait regarder si on peut faire
travailler les créatifs davasse dans le
monde parce que je vous rappelle
qu'avant cela aussi je pense la france
n'est que 20% et que l'étranger et 80%
est-ce qu'on peut les faire travailler
ces gens qui ont 25 ans 30 ans 32 ans
avec des créateurs de séries pour voir
si on peut faire des formats c'était une
des idées à l'époque qui avaient été mis
en oeuvre et c'est pour ça que vous en
avait parlé à l'époque
sylvie robert
oui merci monsieur le président l'a
beaucoup de questions ont été posées
donc je vais essayer d'aller un peu plus
loin dans la réflexion là qu'est posée
cet après midi
nous avait dit monsieur bolloré donc
c'est une question purement économique
parce que c'est le deuxième secteur des
médias le deuxième secteur le plus
rentable du monde que vous êtes encore
tout petit
vous avez dit également la concentration
des médias posent problème mais ce qui
pose problème c'est la taille de nos
concurrents
quand j'entends le encore ça veut dire
que vous considérez qu'il faut
concentrer encore plus pour affronter la
taille de ses concurrents qui pose
problème
donc quelle est votre stratégie à venir
même si on sait très bien et que vous
n'êtes que conseiller que vous allez
passer la main mais ce qu'on voudrait
comprendre
c'est que et mes collègues l'ont dit
indirectement on parle de concentration
verticale
verticale d'abord j'aimerais savoir si
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qualificatif
concentration horizontale ou verticale
qui permet finalement de pouvoir
avoir un système intégré je crois que
c'est julien bargeton qui équipe qui le
disaient donc est ce que le encore fait
que vous avez une stratégie pour aller
plus loin est ce que vous considérez que
dans le paysage actuel face à ses
concurrents qui pose problème
on est en capacité de concentrer encore
plus sachant vous avez compris si cette
commission denquête a été créé c'est
bien parce que la question du pluralisme
de la démocratie de la loi de 86 qui est
au coeur de nos débats de la question
forcément de la liberté des rédactions
de l'heure de leur capacité à pouvoir
travailler
librement
est un sujet alors vous réponse on les
comprend mais il ya un il ya un sujet
donc moi j'aimerais que vraiment vous
alliez plus loin pour nous dire et puis
c'est ma deuxième question elle est un
peu c'est quoi pour vous l'information
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie vivante
vivaces qui n'est pas
en terme de qualité je termine débat
public ce qu'on peut voir de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique et enfin et se
terminerait qui aussi revient et c'est
vous l'avez c'est que des journalistes
partent et ça n'est pas rien quand on
apprend que 2 itélé à seignosse après 70
journalistes qui sont partis alors vous
allez me dire ils ont toute la liberté
de partir et sont partis pour
différentes raisons mais ce sont là
aussi des faits vous parliez de fait et
non pas de propos qui interroge qui
questionne et c'est pour ça dans le
débat public et et qu'on est là aussi
pour essayer de comprendre donc voilà
mes questions sont simples parce que
derrière il ya la question de la
démocratie et de l'information dans
notre pays qu'est la france et vous
allez commencer par 10 à 12 ans remercie
que vous êtes attaché vous êtes breton
et moi aussi à la culture française et
romain
d'abord madame la sénatrice les
journalistes sont partis mais les
journées sont revenus sont pas les mêmes
mais c'est comme la mer en bretagne chez
nous elle s'écarte et puis revient voilà
donc le groupe pardon le groupe canal
voilà pardon oui c'est la mer et donc
vous avez des gens qui effrayées s'en
vont et puis vous avez des gens contents
qu'ils viennent et c'est comme ça dans
la vie c'est comme ça dans les partis
politiques c'est comme ça la chambre
c'est comme ça dans les vies
personnelles voilà c'est comme ça il ya
des gens qui partent
peut-être pour des bonnes raisons
peut-être pour me des mauvaises raisons
ils sont d'ailleurs protégés ils ont des
clauses de conscience est très bien
c'est fait pour ça mais il y en a qui
reviennent voilà on n'a pas détruit des
rédactions
ils restent un champ de ruines on a
reconstruit avec des gens qui avaient
envie de construire avec nous pour
différentes raisons ils peuvent trouver
que les équipes que j'ai mises en place
sont des gens avec qui il faut pas
travailler mais c'est leur droit
mais je ne peux pas dire
on a fait partir des gens point non on a
fait partir des gens et les gens en
nombre supérieur sont revenus donc si
vous voulez en termes de construction
c'est la vie et je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose sur vos questions
précédentes sont des sujets importants
alors d'abord sur la concentration dit
horizontale c'est à dire dans le même
secteur je vais vous donner un exemple
très parlant il ya une très grosse
affaire aux etats-unis dans l'édition
qui était à vendre qui s'appelle simon
and schuster
et
achète était trop petit pour l'acheter
et editis était trop petit pour
l'acheter et ensemble ils auraient pu
l'acheter et c'est bertelsmann qu'ils
achetaient
donc on voit bien que le poids et je
voulais montrer tout à l'heure quand on
a regardé la taille même si hachette
editis ce marien
et ça n'arrivera pas 100 kg et
évidemment des mesures qui soient prises
en france parce que les tailles sont
trop importantes mais même s'ils se
mariaient on ne serait encore que les
troisièmes est loin d y ait derrière en
terme de profitabilité de valeur des 1er
mai sur la concentration verticale c'est
sans doute encore plus intéressant parce
que regarder le groupe disney
c'est une concentration parfaitement
verticale personne ne va dire à
eurodisney attendait mais on va pas
mettre blanche neige c'est insupportable
ça fait partie de votre groupe
personne ne dit on va interdire à peter
pan d'aller à eurodisney parce que ça
fait partie de la stratégie de disney
la stratégie tous ces groupes
c'est de faire ce qu'ils appellent du
360° ce qui veut dire en gros on fait un
peu de tout dans tous les sens et il
trouve un personnage
nickel a souri ils font un journal ils
font des dessins animés ils font des
des clubs on peut aller des villages on
peut aller voir les centres de loisirs
et puis un moment
les personnages sont un peu désuet donc
on fait des films avec des acteurs plus
épicée et on reprend blanche neige qui
devient je sais plus quel et l'actrice
qui joue dedans angelina jolie je crois
ou charlize theron opérons je ne sais
plus et puis etc etc et puis un moment
se fait à faire des marvel et apprendre
des super héros et puis à la fin tout ça
marche ensemble et c'est ce fameux soft
power américains
et les asiatiques font pareil alors je
ne voudrais pas vous donner une
impression qu'on va aller faire une
grande machine avec des choses qui
tourne dans tous les sens c'est pas du
tout comme ça que ça se passe pour que
des créatifs reste avec vous il faut
qu'il soit apprécié pour qu'un auteur
puisse écrire son livre être heureux
restez chez vous il faut que vous
puissiez lui donner un cadre qui soit un
cadre personnel donc ce ne sont pas des
grandes machines se sont au contraire
sur mesure des alliances qui sont faites
mais regardez un garçon peut-être tout à
l'heure on passera le film c'est alex
lutz voilà alex lutz est un garçon qui
j'ai commencé comme speakerine entre
guillemets dans des séries de titres
petit truc de canal et qui est
maintenant un des plus grands acteurs
connus à l'international quand on
regarde angèle la chanteuse les
maintenant dans le monde entier etc etc
donc moi je pense que wie 20 10 mes
successeurs s'ils en ont le goût et la
possibilité
ils ont une chance énorme de pouvoir
prendre ces français peu ou pas connus
et de les projeter dans le monde entier
parce que quand on parle de l'émission
là aussi à part quelques auteurs qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent la plupart des
gens dans l'édition crève la faim les
auteurs avec leurs droits d'auteur je
vous assure qu'ils s'en sortent pas et
donc un groupe qui est capable d'aller
prendre
un auteur français lui proposé de
traduire de vendre à l'étranger de faire
des séries ou des plus petits
élément digitaux et de les passer sur
dailymotion canal ou autre je vous
assure moi je pense que c'est un projet
passionnant pour ce fameux soft power
qui est quand même très important pour
la france
bien javier
monsieur bolloré merci vous savez donc
on réfléchit sur les conséquences
finalement de la concentration des
médias et donc moi j'aimerais un peu vos
conseils puisque vous dites que
maintenant c'est votre fonction et en
profiter avant que vous soyez gâteux
comme vous avez dit je pense ça nous
laisse quand même un petit peu de temps
malgré tout
quand vous dites que la motivation c'est
finalement la rentabilité économique
normal d'une entreprise et qu'on a
besoin d'eux de concentration on voit
fasse ça quel mastodonte on a à faire
face est ce qu'un jour pour être on sait
quand même que la culture française que
la francophonie impasse qui est
majoritaire dans le monde est-ce qu'on
ne risque pas un jour de délai c'est
justement la culture française pour un
problème de rentabilité
et est-ce qu'au contraire c'est pas
parce que les petites les plus petites
sociétés celles qui ont que comme
finalement de zone de chalandise que que
le que les gens d'autres cultures et
bien sont pas ceux qui permettent de la
de la faire vivre et scapa donc un
risque dans cette concentration qu'on
souhaite pour résister aux gars femmes
mais qui va être quand même difficile
d'être obligé de rentrer dans une
culture insipide
international et de perdre un petit peu
notre
notre propre culture ce procès est ce
qu'il faut que la la puissance publique
justement soit très contraignantes pour
maintenir à la fois je parte pas
seulement même la pluralité des opinions
dans les médias mais même pour imposer
culture française et là on serait quand
même dans un
dans un système qui serait un peu
coercitif et qui laisserait moins de
liberté donc on est vraiment un moment
voilà des interrogations sur qu'est-ce
qui peut préserver la créativité de la
culture française 100 pour la protéger
pour prune et la priver
de liberté et de créativité et en même
temps par la laisser au contraire
disparaître se diluer dans une culture
internationale pour des raisons de
rendement économique moi je crois
monsieur le sénateur que
mes successeurs yannick bolloré arnault
puis fontaine maxime saada ce sont
convaincus que nous avons un trésor
le trésor c'est notre histoire
alors pardon je vais pas le droit de
dire clovis charlemagne c'est très mal
vu aujourd'hui mais enfin quand même bon
on a des sites on a des lieux on a des
endroits magnifiques qu'on peut filmer
et moi je pense que c'est ce trésor qui
peut être mis en avant et qui peut être
exporté quand on fait vers ça et quand
on fait clovis voilà c'est plus
intéressant quand on fait superman 2 3 4
5 6 7 etc etc c'est passionnant c'est
formidable mais peut-être que de temps
en temps on peut aller vers quelque
chose d'un peu plus subtil un peu plus
raffiné et nos aïeux nous ont laissé ça
et moi je pense que si vous favorisez
des groupes français ou en tout cas vous
ne les empêchait pas de vivre et vous me
favorisée par des étrangers qui eux ont
une arrière-pensée complètement
différente de ce qui les intéresse
pardon c'est éventuellement de prendre
pied en france et ensuite ces deux
normaliser le même film dans le monde
entier dont il ya peu de chance en effet
que soit la culture française qui s'en
sort mais si vous réussissez à garder ou
à faire émerger ou empêcher disparaître
des groupes qui ont cette volonté
moi je pense que vous réussirez parce
que nous avons une vraie richesse et que
je pense que les talents et les
résultats se conjuguent
universal music c'est à la fois des
talents formidables et les résultats et
moi je pense que canal vivendi peut
faire la même chose lagardère regarder
lagardère tout le monde parle de
lagardère
c'est intéressant peut-être de regarder
ce groupe moi j'ai bien connu jean luc
lagardère il a laissé à son fils arnaud
une situation compliquée puisqu'il
n'avait que 5 % du capital quelque chose
comme ça et il avait fait une commandite
qui est un organisation qui est à la
fois un château fort mais pas
complètement indestructible qu'est ce
qu'il a à faire nous lagardère la
première chose qu'il a faite quand il a
pris la suite de son père il s'est
endetté pour acheter des actions pour
montrer à ses équipes et au monde entier
qu'il avait confiance et qui voulait
développer ce groupe c'est courageux de
le faire
ils se retrouvent ensuite
avec
une pandémie qui touche un secteur très
important et pourtant je vous dis il a
été courageux il a été engagé il a
internationalisé parce que l'essentiel
vachette c'est pas la france s'est à
nouveau l'international moi je pense à
fait partie des groupes qu'il faut
soutenir ce qu'a fait l'état d'ailleurs
avec le pg e à un moment
et c'est ce que nous faisons c'est le
soutien d'arnaud lagardère de son groupe
et sa politique donc est ce que ces lois
et les pouvoirs publics qu'ils font
est-ce que ça doit être des fonds privés
je ne sais pas mais ce sont ces groupes
qui créeront demain la richesse de la
france arnaud lagardère peux vous dire
on habite au même endroit il aime ce
pays donc on a intérêt plutôt à les
sauver aider des gens comme ça plutôt
que des étrangers qui viennent et qui
vous dit bonjour qui sont très aimables
et puis dans deux ans vous les verrez
plus jamais et moi je suis très
impressionné sur la chronologie des
médias qui est une chose vous parlez des
mesures à prendre c'est quand même
quelque chose d'extraordinaire on est en
train d'ouvrir la porte à des grandes
plateformes
c'est formidable où amazon avec le foot
on est obligé d'ouvrir la porte je vous
dis à nouveau le groupe vivendi
s'adaptera 200 ans dans les pattes on en
fera sans doute quelques années de plus
encore mais
votre rôle à mon avis et voilà c'est
notre pays les étrangers défendre leur
pays les allemands regarder ce que font
les allemands regardent et bertelsmann
vous parliez tout à l'heure des delà de
la concentration
des gens qui travaillaient les uns avec
les autres j'ai un slide là-dessus qui
est assez intéressant qui est le dise si
vous voulez bien le passé monsieur voilà
regardez les groupes ils sont tous dans
le tv édition presse radio autre nom le
dise
voilà voilà répartition du chiffre
d'affaires par activité
oui ils sont tous à travailler ensemble
ne sont pas dans les ports en afrique
non mais d'abord écouter partout des
mois comme vous savez on est obligé d'en
sortir donc je le regrette d'ailleurs
parce que là on pense que c'est un
continent qui est à nos portes
il va y avoir deux milliards d'habitants
c'est la chine de demain voilà donc je
regrette qu'on était
malheureusement
obligés de partir mais ces jeux
pardonnez moi non mais attendez je
comprends ce que vous direz qu'on vous
dise ou le btp des groupes de presse en
allemagne
franchement est ce que on peut pas dire
que voilà que j'essaye de favoriser
monsieur bouygues au cours d'une
commission mais enfin je vois pas ce que
c'est un français qui est très bien qui
gère ses affaires remarquablement bien
lui aussi est arrivé avec une situation
un peu complexe y'a rien à lui reprocher
peut-être bon c'est pas un groupe il
s'est internationalisé mais je ne vois
pas
je moi personnellement problème je ne
rejoins je parle pas votre classe
précise je précise vous donner un
exemple qui est les groupes allemands et
leurs investissements importants et leur
grandeur dans le domaine des médias et
de la presse oui
avec une particularité c'est que ce sont
des bouts de médias et de presse etc en
france sont des investisseurs qui
viennent d'autres mondes et j'ai cité le
beige le btp etc c'est pareil dans les
autres séries débat en italie c'est
pareil le groupe berlusconi a fait
beaucoup d'autres choses que de la
presse le groupe caltagirone dans le
bâtiment etc partout dans le monde
mon avis sur le
peuplant la constitution des groupes moi
je le vois vrai qu'il ya un point dans
votre stratégie que j'ai du mal à suivre
c'est pourquoi laisser partir universal
music jeu il ya cinq ans vous nous
expliquer ici même que
avoir universal music était un élément
extrêmement fort du groupe et on
comprend parfaitement en plus c'est un
des leaders mondiaux dans son secteur et
là on voit bien dans la dans la vision
de vivendi aujourd'hui vous mettez sur
le
cd des actions de d'universal music le
remettre sur le marché
quelle est l'idée derrière le fait que
vous quittiez cet univers de la musique
avec un leader mondial existants comme
universal music alors le groupe bolloré
n'a pas du tout quitté universal music
où on a toujours les 320 millions
d'actions et universal music qu'on avait
il ya cinq ans et qu'on a aujourd'hui on
en a pas vendu une seule mais un certain
nombre d actionnaires de vivendi qui
sont blackrock legal and général pisam
et autres fonds elliott il y en a qui
disait ça vaudra beaucoup moins d'autres
qui disait ça vaudra beaucoup plus et
ils ont demandé depuis que nous sommes
arrivés depuis le premier jour à ce que
les activités soient séparés mais nous
en tant que groupe bolloré nous avons le
même pourcentage dans le groupe
universal plus en arrivant donc nous ne
l'avons pas lâcher d'où l'intérêt à
favoriser c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure ou en tout cas ne pas nuire pour
des groupes français qui ont envie de
continuer à se développer parce que la
vérité c'est que vivendi comme je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure l'essentiel du
capital il est détenu par des fonds
étrangers
70% du capital de vivendi +2 70% du
capital de vivendi est détenue par des
fonds qui si demain matin canal+ ne
marche pas ou dailymotion et vendus par
orange ne lèveront pas le petit doigt
parce que ça ne les intéresse pas alors
qu'à mon avis yannick bolloré arnault
puis fontaine
jean christophe thiery et autres ils
sont français ils ont envie de continuer
d aventure en tout cas c'est ce que
j'espère j'ai essayé de bâtir ma
succession pour que justement il y ait
cette affectio societatis qui a fait
qu'on a réussi à tenir deux cents ans ça
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'entreprises dans
le monde qui sont capables de rester 200
ans malgré deux guerres mondiales
plusieurs révolutions des évolutions
techniques des disputes familiales tout
ce que voulait des évolutions de
produits et qui sont toujours au même
endroit et à développer le même pays
grand
bonjour monsieur bolloré je voudrais
vous faire part à mon tour de trois
motifs d'inquiétude ou trois questions
j'ai proposé la première depuis le début
de l'audition vous employez à vous
présenter comme un groupe
modest pas si important que ça
en vérité quand on regarde un peu le
paysage où il ya très peu d'acteurs dans
le paysage
l'information est dans le paysage
audiovisuel français aujourd'hui en
dehors du service public cinq six
groupes contrôlent maintenant bientôt
l'essentiel donc en fait vous êtes un
des acteurs importants
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que vous
dites on a parlé d' havas vous savez
bien que la publicité par exemple est
une question pas seulement marcher c'est
une question stratégique pour la survie
de beaucoup de titres
cédés points qui sont quand même assez
stratégique dans la situation mais à
propos de cette question il ya une chose
sur lesquels vous n'avez rien dit c'est
quelles sont vos appétits futur vous
êtes ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui vous
avez grossi dans la dernière période
est ce que vous voulez grossir j'ai
compris en creux dans votre discours que
c'était votre ambition
donc jusqu'où vous pensez que un groupe
peut aller de la part de contrôle
dans un secteur comme celui là sans
mettre en cause
les principes du pluralisme
de la diversité de la création ça c'est
ma première question la seconde une
seconde au type d'inquiétude c'est sur
le modèle
vous dites mon projet économique et moi
j'ai un critère en fait d'où l'avait
répété à plusieurs reprises c'est la
rentabilité mais et vous dites je veux
devenir un champion de la culture
française et européenne vous avez ni
dans le propos liminaire
mais la culture française et européenne
singulièrement la culture française
c'est pas seulement la rentabilité
lamont sol ce que si c'était ça il n'y
aurait pas justement la diversité
actuelle de il s'agit pas de faire des
queues des groupes qui perdent de
l'argent mais que je prends un exemple
qui évidemment l'intérêt par rapport à
canal le cinéma français
si nous avions copier les américains il
ya 20 ou 30 ans il y aurait plus de
cinéma français et probablement pub
cinéma en repères pour ce qu'il en est
nous avons inventé en france un modèle
original et qui ne s'est pas appuyé
seulement sur des champions qui
s'appuyait sur des politiques publiques
la taxation des billets etc on a créé un
écosystème qui a permis et il ya des
acteurs y compris privés qui ont joué ce
jeu là qui ont accepté ces règles et qui
au nom justement de la culture
françaises ont joué un rôle tout
particulier vous avez cité jean luc
lagardère il se trouve que dans une
autre vie puisque véhiculons la presse
quelques années je l' ai connu aussi la
gale jean luc lagardère a par exemple
porter un bout de bras j'dirais pendant
des années le système de distribution
mutualisé de la presse française et pas
pour des raisons de rentabilité
mais par attachement à une certaine
conception du pluralisme
lorsque j'entends dans votre modèle
j'entends pas beaucoup ça à quoi donc
j'entends plutôt un modèle qui
ressemblerait à ce que est ce que font
les américains et je suis pas sûr que en
matière culturelle puisque vous dites
être un champion de la culture française
européenne ce soit l'eau modèle
qui soit le modèle le plus pertinent
pour porter justement la culture
française ou la culture européenne où
les valeurs qu'on a supporté et enfin
une dernière remarque je m'excuse de
revenir là dessus mais puisque vous avez
cessé venu plusieurs fois à propos de
eric zemmour en est puisque vous avez
fait référence jeu je dois dire que je
m'étonne que vous banalisez cette
question d'autant plus que vous avez
fait référence en parlant de notre
histoire familiale à la résistance
il se trouve que je suis d'une famille
politique qui est assez sensible à cette
question aussi
à
moi j'ai une grand-mère qui
figure parmi les justes parlait pas
renié la nation parce qu'elle a sauvé
des enfants juifs qu'elle a risqué sa
vie pour ça
non eric zemmour c'est pas une opinion
comme une autre
hier c'est la troisième fois qu'il est
condamné pour incitation à la haine
raciale
et quand il a fait les déclarations
qu'il a fait sur la question de vichy
oui c'est un problème pour la démocratie
française
donc prendre la responsabilité
évidemment il a son opinion il ya des
français qui peuvent penser comme eux et
il y en a malheureusement manifestement
mais prendre la responsabilité
de lui de lui donner de la place
éditoriale
c'est pas c'est pas comme une autre pour
ou alors sinon ça veut dire que les
jugements répété
à son égard sur la question du
racisme ne compte pour rien mais en
démocratie c'est je crois que peut-être
tombés d'accord sur l'idée que le
racisme n'est pas opinion comme une
autre c'est un délit
donc je crois que sur cette question je
crois que la banalisation
n'est pas n'est pas acceptable
sur cette troisième question vous
connaissez le mot
attribuée à voltaire je crois justement
mais que me répéter un ami je ne partage
pas vos idées mais je me battrai pour
que plus fier les exprimer
en ce qui concerne voilà vous voyez je
vais vous montrer un truc personnel que
j'ai qui est un petit mot du général de
gaulle à mon père
à michel bolloré en souvenir de notre
combat commun
voilà donc je pense que sur le plan de
la démocratie et du reste voilà j'ai un
adn qui va bien
je vous dis monsieur zemmour il était
sur toutes les autres chaînes il était
encore qu'on est on l'a retiré de ses
news il est chez bfm tous les soirs
je voudrais savoir pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que c'est uniquement sur
chez nous que ça porte vous recevez les
gens de bfm ou le rempart les voleurs
demander pourquoi ils viennent comment
ça se passe et ce qu'il a le droit de
s'exprimer ou pas - 10 avril monsieur
bolloré parce que vous avez bien sûr
mais n'ont en effet pas je le dis a
beaucoup d'essais sans dire que j'essaie
de vous dire que dans le groupe canal et
dans ce que nous sommes en train de
bâtir le fait politique ne représente
même pas 1% donc on peut parvenir
indéfiniment à dire que tout ce qu'on
construit c'est pour des raisons
politiques c'est par la réalité c'est
pas la réalité des fêtes de la même
façon que c'est pas la réalité des fêtes
qu'on est tout puissant vous voulez
montrer on est tout petit mais
de même nous ne sommes pas la recherche
uniquement de rentabilité je me suis mal
exprimé auprès de vous parce que ce que
j'ai dit c'est qu'au contraire je pense
qu'il faut aller vers les contenus vers
les talents mais que ça n'est pas
incompatible d'avoir de la rentabilité
parce que toute façon s'il n'y a pas de
rentabilité à un moment ou un autre
tueur a plus de talent il y aura plus de
contenu qui pourront continuer mais bon
vous me dites
la culture française on l'a protégé mais
attendez vous êtes en train de détruire
avec la chronologie des médias tout ce
que vous avez fait pour protéger le
cinéma qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient canal
avait du succès avec son cinéma
c'est parce que il fallait attendre deux
ans sur les plateformes étrangères ou
trois ans c'était plus qu'elle était
défi pour aller voir les films
américains et les films français vous
allez voir maintenant pratiquement en
même temps sur canal dont vous êtes
pardonnez-moi à nouveau je vous dis
canal se débrouillera mais vous pouvez
pas dire à la fois on protège c'est
grâce à nous et à la fois prendre des
mesures que vous êtes en train de
prendre vous prenez exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il faut pour aider le
cinéma français et moi je vous dis vous
détruire et le cinéma français parce
qu'il n'y aura plus à ce moment là même
si vous avez des plateformes que 5 ou 10
films par an important qui seront
financées par les plateformes alors que
nous on n'en finance 250 par an enfin du
canal sur la suite et la fin
moi je ne veux pas grossir moi mon
ambition c'est de fêter le 17 février le
bicentaire du groupe et ergué gabéric
avec ceux qui me succède
si je peux y aller avec l'épidémie qui
espère
mes successeurs
qu'on se connaît puisque c'est j'ai
contribué beaucoup elle est nommée et ça
là dessus je ne me dérobe pas non plus
les gens qui seront en poste sont des
gens voilà alors
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire derrière
j'espère leur avoir poussé à essayer de
défendre cette culture française et moi
en tout cas quand je les entends parler
devant moi
ils me disent tous voila c'est ce qu'on
a envie de faire
mais c'est vrai que vous disiez tout à
fait monsieur le sénateur on prend des
coups tout le temps c'est vrai
voilà moi j'ai la peau un peu abîmée les
vieux sanglier donc c'est pas agréable
mais je fais avec mes des jeunes qui
arrivent
c'est un peu compliqué de faire des
procès d'intention
sur des réalités qui n'en sont pas
forcément
alors voilà j'espère que ça continuera
et je vous remercie en tout cas beaucoup
de m'avoir reçus et écoutés encore vous
voulez moi je reste au temps de jeu je
précise juste que la chronologie des
médias ne dépend pas du parlement
maintenant épreuve interprofessionnelle
valider ou pas par le gouvernement donc
d'accord
vincent capo-canellas
merci président merci monsieur bolloré
vous êtes un grand capitaine d'industrie
vous avez affiché tout à l'heure des
objectifs deux rives mans culturelle de
la france à l'international
vous avez enfin dit que vous êtes
démocrate chrétien et je ne peux qu'être
sensible à ça pas seulement au dernier
point d'ailleurs alors les démocrates
chrétiens savent que les communes
colline marché c'est la base et sont
aussi soucieux l'équilibrage et trois
questions première question en termes d'
équilibre économique
est-ce que vous pensez que les médias
audiovisuels devrait pouvoir évoluer
vers des médias d'opinion un peu comme
la presse écrite
et que ça leur permettrait de mieux
trouver leur public et donc peut-être de
mieux assurer leur indépendance
premier première question ce que les
médias donc aller vers des médias
d'opinion deuxièmement quand vous voyez
l'exemple de télés étrangères comme fox
news qu'est ce que ça vous inspire et
enfin troisièmement sur le choix des
éditorialistes on a compris tout à
l'heure que vous vient alors une
capacité de détection enfin en tout cas
où de choix de talent aujourd'hui on est
dans un monde où on voit bien que la
culture du clash qui marche dans les
médias et donc on va plutôt vers des
éditorialistes clivant
alors qu'ils n'ont pas faim clivant et
qui est aussi parfois re
apporte aussi une logique d'opinion bon
mais est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
on manque aujourd'hui d'analystes qui
soit aussi moins clivant et qui
donnerait justement notion d' équilibre
à laquelle les démocrates chrétiens sont
sensibles
écoutez moi je regarde pas beaucoup la
télévision pour tout vous dire donc
j'entends de l'extérieur ce qui se passe
sur les chaînes et les sujets etc mais
je sais pas quoi vous dire sur ce qui se
passe à l'étranger en tout cas il ya un
point que se partagent avec le
rapporteur sénateur david assouline
c'est que tant que ce sont des
fréquences hertziennes qui appartiennent
à l'état
l'état doit avoir un contrôle absolu et
je ne vois pas d'intérêt d'aller créer
des chaînes d'opinion moi
personnellement voilà c'est un avis
personnel tant que vous avez c'est votre
fréquence et les fréquences de l'état
l'état doit gérer et dire ce qu'il veut
ou ce qu'il veut pas prêt
moi j'ai pas l'impression de faire des
chaînes d'opinion soit quelque chose de
positif mais honnêtement s'il connaît
pas grand chose parce que vous l'avez vu
on ne représente que 0,1 pour cent des
trucs d'opinion nous je peux vous parler
du cinéma je peux vous parler du sport
si vous voulez je peux vous parler des
séries
sur le plan de l'info c'est un peu plus
compliqué et sur l'étranger je ne
connais pas bien non plus
parce que je ne regarde pas la
télévision étrangère et je ne sais pas
comment ça marche moi je vois arriver
dès des immenses groupes qui sont pour
l'essentiel des plateformes
et je pense que ce sont ceux là les
dangers et vous savez les invasions à
partir du vème siècle on a vu arriver
des très gros et on a cru que c'étaient
les plus gros pas du tout ils fuyaient
devant des gens encore plus gros et moi
je les connais les plus gros parce que
j'ai travaillé avec eux et
sont des groupes très fort
les américains avec les droits de vote
multiples ce sont des personnes qui
possèderont moi même quand j'étais
président sévit 20 10 j'ai été obligé de
tenir compte des actionnaires extérieurs
parce que j'étais pas majoritaires mais
les groupes que vous allez voir arriver
qu'ils sont en train d'arriver sont des
groupes américains avec des majoritaires
avec des droits de vote multiples qui ne
sont pas autorisés en france ou des
asiatiques avec une vision politique
très claire
comment se défendre de ça je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas
jean pierre vergès
monsieur bolloré moi je voulais vous
poser une question ce à plusieurs
questions mais je vais aller très très
vite revenir sur le slate qui est passé
tout à l'heure ça et sur la taille entre
les gars femmes et les médias français
et c 17 un document qu'on nous montre
que les médias français nous montre
souvent et je voulais savoir si dans la
réalité de l'action quotidienne de votre
groupe vous considérez que ce soit
réellement vos concurrents au delà même
de la taille déjà juste peut-être par la
nature des métiers alors ça peut frotter
sur le foot ou des choses comme ça mais
est ce que ce sont réellement vos
concurrents au quotidien est ce que ce
ne sont pas plutôt les groupes qui sont
sur l'autre salaï les axel springer les
bertelsmann donc ma question
premièrement c'est qu'ils sont vos vrais
concurrents et deuxièmement votre avis
sur le rapprochement tf1 m6 qui est un
des sujets qui a participé à créer cette
commission
tf1 m6 qui nous disent sans rien au
slide il faut qu'on se regroupe pour
être plus forts et concurrencer les gars
femme est ce que vous croyez à la
réalité de cet argument ou est ce que
vous pensez qu on est plutôt sur deux
entreprises qui sont sur un métier qui
font que les amis avec des habitudes de
consommation qu'ils changent ils font
qu'il ya un besoin de se regrouper
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs pour que baisser
les coûts de fonctionnement et maintenir
les marges
et pensez vous que ce rapprochement est
de nature à bousculer le marché je parle
notamment des pubs la répartition des
richesses qui aurait sur le marché
pensez vous que cela peut avoir des
conséquences sur les médias français
nous ne concurrençons ce que je vous ai
indiqué sur le sur le side sur le
tableau nous nos concurrents sont ceux
qui viennent faire des plates formes de
cinéma ou de séries donc c'est apple
c'est amazon vous savez que amazon vous
êtes amazon prime dès que vous achetez
après ce légume à 24 euros vous êtes
automatiquement amazon prime et vous
avez tous les contenus gratos de toutes
les séries et tous les films donc bon
apple vous avez vu ce qu'ils font
netflix
vous avez vu aussi le développement
qu'ils ont et
donc nous nos concurrents c'est ce que
je vous ai indiqué j'ai pas bertelsmann
et axel springer
tf1 m6 la différence avec nous c'est que
tf1 et m6 sont des groupes français dont
l'essentiel de leurs activités en france
nous on est un groupe pardon on est
d'ergué gabéric
on est français
mais l'essentiel notre activité est à
l'étranger
c'est un rayonnement étrangers
est ce que ça vient poser des problèmes
je suis pas le mieux placé pour répondre
franchement j'en sais rien je vous dis
c'est plus je ne suis pas en concurrence
il faudrait recevoir banide g qu'on a
essayé d'aider ce qu'on va aider grâce à
nous vive un dj a réussi à devenir le
numéro un mondial des des programmes de
flux on a apporté les centaines de
millions nécessaires qu' il n'aurait pas
trouvé sinon et qui n'auraient pas pu
faire mais moi je peux pas vous répondre
parce que je connais pas bien la télé
gratuite française conditions à télé
gratuite française on est insignifiant
chaque ligne de stats brigneau qu'il est
derrière son écran
bonjour merci monsieur le président
monsieur aurait évidemment entendu tout
ce que vous avez dit depuis que vous
avez commencé cette audition alors mon
collègue monsieur ghosn est à a dit au
tout début de ces propos que des gens
qui réussissent elles dans notre pays
entraîner soit le respect soit la
suspicion cas moi je voulais vous dire
que vous avez tout mon respect je tenais
à le dire vraiment parce que voilà des
hommes qui se construisent et des hommes
qui font travailler des milliers
d'autres hommes je pense que on doit
leur donner on doit dire le respect
lorsque en tout cas c'est mon cas moi je
voudrais je voulais voilà vous avez dit
également monsieur bolloré que je ne
faisais pas politique mais nous on en
fait et autour cette tape les sénateurs
qui vous entourent ou qui le regardent
en visio font de la politique donc cette
commission enquête elle a un objectif
c'est de se poser la question sur la
concentration
des médias voilà un certain nombre
d'auditions en tout cas on a entendu à
plusieurs reprises que pour
un certain nombre de chercheurs ou de
gens qui réfléchissent est sûre ça sur
ce sujet ce n'était pas un souci ce
n'était pas un problème mais j'ai écouté
aussi tous mes collègues sénateurs pour
un certain nombre de sénateurs c'est une
vraie question de remise en cause
probable de la démocratie et d'ailleurs
je le dis je voulais dire monsieur le
président de la commission il ya des
propos qui ont été tenus aujourd'hui qui
me choque beaucoup qui ne sont pas du
tout liés à l'audition de monsieur
bolloré je pense que les procès
d'intention sont pas toujours très sains
dans les commissions c'est la première
fois d'ailleurs que je le dit lors d'une
commission d' enquête ou d'une
commission d'information
il ya des propos qui n'ont aucun rapport
avec la mission de notre commission
d'enquêté je voulais le dire voilà non
je pense que c'était important tout cas
pour moi c'était important que je le
dise et certains de mes collègues aussi
sénateurs ont sans arrêt signé mzee mots
moi je n'ai aucun souci je ne suis pas
une fanatique du tout de ces mots mais
tout comme monsieur mélenchon monsieur
zemmour un droit de parler je pense que
c'est l'honneur de notre démocratie et
de notre diversité d'opinion que de
pouvoir exprimer les choses qui sont
juste l'expression de français
malheureusement parfois il faut aussi se
poser la question sur d'entre eux le
politique quand on en arrive à avoir
d'eric zemmour qui font de tels scores
dans les sondages ça nous pousse à nous
poser des questions plutôt qu'à la
presse moi je voulais aussi revenir je
voulais avoir votre peut-être avis même
si vous nous avait expliqué que vous
n'étiez pas directement impliqués dont
l'organisation des rédactions et du
recrutement des journalistes que je
crois on se pose beaucoup aujourd'hui la
question de la concentration des grands
groupes en ce qui concerne les médias on
se pose jamais la question d'ailleurs du
pluralisme du service public mais ça ça
pose deux questions à personne moi je me
pose la question du pluralisme dans un
avis public peut-être ça fera l'objet
d'une autre commission alors deux
petites questions mais peut-être que
deux petites réflexions que vous
pourriez nous donner monsieur bolloré
s'est d'abord est-ce que vous pensez que
dans les médias il n'ya les outils
suffisants
pour préserver
ce pluralisme nécessaire qu'il y à notre
démocratie a vraiment ça je pense que
c'est important est ce que moi c'est
qu'il ya les outils suffisants
pense que c'est important et est ce que
vous pensiez qu'on se pose les mêmes
questions du pluralisme pour le service
public qui je le rappelle fonctionne
avec l'argent des citoyens avec l'argent
des français donc est-ce qu'on se pose
les mêmes questions selon vous est-ce
que la suspicion est plutôt faite sur
les grands groupes privés voilà merci
monsieur le président merci pour vos
propos si
agréable madame la sénatrice merci
beaucoup moi je trouve qu'il ya le
pluralisme à titre personnel mais je
vous dis je ne suis pas un consommateur
de télévision énorme parce que mes
journées commencent très tôt finissent
très tard et j'ai malheureusement pas le
temps
quoique
my canal est un outil informatique
formidable digital qui permet de
récupérer un peu plus tard mais même si
je rentre à 20h30 et que après avoir
mangé rapidement je veux regarder il me
reste une heure une heure et demie deux
heures maximum donc j'ai pas le temps
d'absorber tout ça moi j'ai le sentiment
que notre pays il ya le pluralisme j'ai
l'impression tout le monde peut
s'exprimer que l'on voit là on aider on
est des gaulois part il faut pas le dire
non plus mais enfin bon bon
chacun chacun exprime ce qu'il a à le
dire et moi je trouve qu'il ya ce le
pluralisme et honnêtement sur le service
public j'ai rien à dire de particulier
c'est vrai que
moi en tant qu paratonnerre j'ai vu
passer toutes les critiques possibles
voilà
c'est vrai que
les trucs me concernant si on faisait
une revue de presse si on faisait les
mêmes calculs qu'il y avait été fait
pour savoir si
havas mais plus de publicité sur nos
chaînes et compte y est ce que le
service public dit plus de mâles du
groupe bolloré que de bien s'en douter y
aurait des pourcentages mais c'est la
démocratie c'est comme ça il faut
l'accepter
moi je suis pas là pour qu'on me dresse
des couronnes de fleurs même si ça fait
très plaisir merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice j'essaye simplement de
rétablir des fêtes qui sont que voilà il
n'y a pas de dans le groupe canal
c'est pour ça que si motorisés sur le
président j'aimerais bien quand même
passé mon petit truc de deux minutes si
monsieur le rapporteur veut bien et on
fera les questions après n'en voulait
pas bon allez vous les avez les fils ah
bon alors attendez c'est peut-être sur
une autre
peut-être que voulez
vous pouvez nous l'envoyer ce sera un
document c'est perdre et si ses yeux pas
forcément dans les salles de projection
de ce c'était pour montrer en résumé que
voilà sur les antennes de canal pendant
que j'en étais président et pendant que
c'était la période la plus dure tout le
monde s'amusait à dire du mal de moi sur
les antennes de canal et qu'il n'y avait
pas de sujet
non je le dis ça je dis ça c'est pas
bien rebondir si les serrures attentes
oui alors justement
vous avez
montré encore ce soir que vous avez
aussi le sens de l'humour mais
sauf quand ils s'exercent à votre
encontre
ou même pas votre encontre d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas apprécié les guignols de
l'info le vous n'avez pas reconduit en
2018 grille il ya une anecdote pouvait
peut-être pour l'anecdote le confirmer
mais à un moment donné vous aviez émis
l'idée dit-on d'écrire vous même les
sketches
des guignols
licenciement d'europe 1 de bertrand
chamerois le 2 juillet 2020 après une
chronique vous concernant c'était
d'ailleurs une chronique plutôt réussie
au demeurant
licenciement ce surprenant de sébastien
thoen de canal+ en novembre 2020 pour
une parodie de leurs des pros
émissions phares de ces news
licenciement de stéphane guillon
franchement
de la même chaîne parce que il a déclaré
soutenir et s'étonner du licenciement de
sébastien thoen
départ de nicolas canteloup d'europe 1
après une chronique vous concernant donc
la question c'est un peu pour conclure
vous avez développé les raisons
profondes de votre investissement dans
les médias votre vision
cela c'est l'objet même de nos débats et
de l'analyse au fond que l'on doit avoir
parce que ce que vous avez développé à
votre façon c'est ce que d'autres qui se
concentre aussi des médias il faut que
des puissants supérieure à la vôtre
disent en gros cette histoire des
plateformes dégâts femmes des chinois xi
et qu'il faut des grands gros pour
pouvoir assurer la concurrence pour
défendre la france vous ajoutez vous et
la culture française vous n'avez pas
défini pour vous ce qu'est la culture
française mais en tous les cas c'est ce
que vous affirmez et quand on vous
projetez vous même les les graphiques
pour nous montrer
la taille des uns et des autres et
justement c'est ce qui est pas
convaincant mais on va continuer nous à
travailler là dessus pour répondre à
cette question c'est que si c'est pour
résister aux la fable
quand apple fait 15 milliards en une
année et je parle pas de nec fit amazon
et tous les autres et que tout
l'audiovisuel français vous mais aussi
le service public tf1 m6 etc font 5
milliards d'investissements en cinq ans
la concurrence en terme de puissance
financière et capacités de production
sont dérisoires que vous avez dit vous
même il ya les nains bon face à des gens
et donc la résistance
la défense de nos valeurs plus que
seulement la culture française nos
valeurs républicaines
c'est un modèle qu'on a construit avec
des régulations pour que la diversité et
le pluralisme
l'indépendance la liberté des médias la
diffusion culturelle la création puisse
être toujours là et donc c'est pour cela
c'était
assez fastidieux probablement que j'ai
lu l'ensemble
de ce que vous contrôlez
c'était long mais ça montre est quand
même que sur le terrain français cette
diversité risque d'être appauvri
quand c'est un même propriétaire
qui contrôlent quasiment toutes les
maisons d'édition et donc quand on lit
des livres on sait que le propriétaire
ou quand on veut faire un livre bien
s'il ne veut pas ou si il veux favoriser
telle lecture et bien et d'un pouvoir
dont on abuse ou pas mais il a un
pouvoir c'est pareil pour la télé c'est
pareil pour la radio c'est pareil pour
la presse écrite et donc il faudrait
accepter se dire pourvu que le
propriétaire n'abuse pas de ce pouvoir
et
vous vous avez c'est nous convaincre que
vous n'intervenez pas et vous n'abusez
jamais de ce pouvoir
or
les faits puisque vous m'avez interpellé
sur les faits montrent que quand une
rédaction
n'est pas d'accord
on lui on lui fait prendre la porte qu'
il ya des interventions pour nommer des
gens en général
de la même
école ou école de pensée on va dire même
si vous dites vous fait pas de politique
mais personne aujourd'hui ne peut
ignorer ce que sont les faits de tous
ceux qui sont nommés et ce que l'on
entend sur des antennes que l'on entend
par ailleurs et sur le pluralisme parce
que bien entendu on auditionnera le
service public et toutes les questions
sont les bienvenus sur l'indépendance le
pluralisme de tous les médias --y
compris le service public mais
très franchement
je vous ai parlé de faits
quant à europe 1 la rédaction d'i on
peut plus travailler avec notre liberté
dont coupât quant à itélé c'est le cas
bien entendu qui a le même nombre
d'employés qui vient derrière et il n'y
a pas de perte sèche mais les cette
liberté qui existe des rédactions et du
travail journalistique
vous êtes un interventionniste assez
direct
vous dit non et bien
voilà nous sommes dans une commission
denquête où une soixantaine d'hommes sur
les chemins nettement sur europe 1 je
n'ai vu aucun journaliste donc je ne
sais même pas comment vous pouvez
affirmer que j'ai fait partir des
journalistes non mais personne ne m'a vu
c'est la réputation qui est fait oui non
mais c'est la vérité c'est ça c'est la
réputation qui est fait donc fait que je
finis ma question dans tous tes
fantasmes
tout eréputation alors c'est vrai
monsieur coloré que nous savons que dans
le domaine des médias l'autocensure par
crainte parent va vouloir
10 ont
suscité le courroux
d'un actionnaire existe mais
voilà en tous les cas que vous nous
disiez ici que vous vous souciez en rien
de la ligne éditorial et des contenus
des médias que vous possédez ne m'a pas
convaincu et vous avez ce qu'ils versent
un nombre de questions qui vous
interpellez concrètement là dessus celle
que je viens de dire c'est
encore tous ses départs
d'humoristes ou deux personnes qui ont
osé vous critiquez
a bien sûr voilà non mais écoutez je
reviens en arrière on va laisser par
monsieur blu ray laissez pas votre jeu
ne s'est pas votre adn kg en question on
a tous un adn est donc un respect absolu
pour l'histoire de votre famille pour la
résistance est
vraiment absolue mais c'est d'autant
plus étonnant moi je ne vous connais pas
personnellement et on m'a toujours
raconter votre histoire familiale ce qui
est très étonnant c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer sur des antennes que
vous possédez et monsieur pierre laurent
l'a évoqué ce ne sont pas des valeurs de
la république et donc ce n'est pas une
question simple de pluralisme mais
d'actes délictueux qui sont condamnés
par la justice et vous nous avez à aucun
moment dans l'audition dit que vous
condamnez comme la justice l'a fait les
propos d'eric zemmour qui sont aux
questions vous l'hérésie répondre que
jamais dans la gestion vous nous allons
refaire comme le condamner en forme de
conclusion je vous laisse répondre sinon
mes e-mails gabo pardon d'abord sur les
gars femmes etc j'ai pas dit qu'il
fallait nous défendre contre les gars
femmes j'ai dit qu'on se débrouillerait
tout mon audition c'était pour expliquer
au contraire qu on s'adaptera et j'ai
expliqué qu'au cours des 200 dernières
années on s'est adapté la guerre a
arrêté les usines enfin bref ne pas
m'arrêter là dessus voilà le groupe
s'adaptera donc je vous ai pas demandé
de nous protéger simplement je dis vous
êtes en train de faire exactement le
contraire après si c'est votre choix par
nature moi je suis démocrate chrétien
assurément et démocrates assurément et
donc si c'est votre choix vous êtes élu
du peuple
si c'est votre choix de ouvrir la porte
aux gars femmes pour détruire canal mois
la limite de fait ce que vous voulez
pichana l'ira se débrouillera s'adaptera
ce qui fait d'ailleurs à travers my
canal est ce qui fait dans les alliances
puisque maintenant nous distribuons
netflix et nous sommes aussi on
distributeur de binh donc on peut pas
faire autrement donc si vous voulez nous
on n'est pas du tout à venir dire aidez
nous aidez nous on dit simplement primum
non nocere et si on pouvait avoir quand
on parle de tf1 m6 là aussi ce vous
décider souverainement mais il faut pas
qu'il y ait deux poids deux mesures
c'est la seule chose que je dis sur
l'ensemble après sur les fêtes sur notre
taille et en particulier sur notre
taille dans l'intervention politique
c'est incontestable vous et montrez on
est tout petit alors on fait beaucoup de
bruit autour de nous mais on est encore
tout petit est ce qu'on va grandir j'en
sais rien c'est pas moi c'est mes
successeurs je l'espère
sur le reste moi je pense que la liberté
d'expression est quelque chose de très
important que toutes ces expressions à
ma connaissance on sur le groupe met à
nouveau je vous redis sur canal vous
nous faites un procès comme si on était
tf1 ou l'a6 où l'aca compte ce qu'ils
disent et les gens qui passent sur leurs
antennes nous dans le temps d'antenne
regardé par les gens
99.99 je vous redis c'est des sports
mécaniques c'est du cinéma donc on vient
nous chercher sur quelque chose qui est
voilà et quant à eric zemmour je vous
redis il passe sur l'a6 ils passent dans
le figaro
et il était sur i télé avant que
j'arrive donc je veux dire moi je veux
bien être le père d'eric zemmour putatif
comme vous le présenter ma faim quand
même voilà et puis quand on écrit que je
lui téléphone tous les jours je déjeune
tous les mois avec lui si je dis rien on
dit c'est que c'est vrai et si je fais
un procès en disant c'est pas vrai sur
quoi vous basez vous ont dit que des
procès bâillon voilà une fois que j'ai
dit que j'assumais des paratonnerres
j'assume des paratonnerres voilà et je
vous redis je pense que vous allez
recevoir les dirigeants du groupe canal
vous allez recevoir j'espère les
dirigeants de vivendi je pense que vous
avez là un groupe patriotes français
dynamique
et
j'espère qu'il continuera
merci à jour merci infiniment merci
monsieur bolloré d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors désolé pour la vidéo on
a un problème de forme pas grave on veut
encore c'est étonnant très haut la
porter à souligner que sur les chaînes
tout le monde se moque de moi et que ils
sont encore là mais nous regarderons
c'est pas des yeux reflètent une bonne
réputation que je fais en montrant ce
film c'est peut-être si le ciel il faut
pas le montrer si je rappelle à nos
collègues que nous auditionnons demain
matin bernard arnault voyez
10h30 de mémoire